the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the weather is beautiful and so is the
play at the super bet chess classic in
bucharest romania the titans of world
chess brought their best hoping to gain
ground in an exceptional field brilliant
attacks inspired equally ingenious
defenses as close calls were saved with
tactical draws ian napomniachi pressed
against surging phenom alireza perugia
in a complicated game with napomiacci
notching his first victory who will gain
ground and who will falter day three of
fighting chess coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day three of
the 2022 superbad chess classic the
first stop of the grand chess tour held
here in beautiful bucharest romania the
players have been giving us plenty of
excitement trails and spills and they
are ready to continue the action in
today's round let's go to the studio and
start the action with yasser peter and
alejandra
enjoy this beautiful sunny uh bucharest
romania as we welcome you to our
coverage of the super bed chess classic
the first stop on the 2022 grand chess
tour hi i'm peter svidler and with me is
yasuo sarawan good morning good morning
peter hello everyone and welcome to our
live coverage of round three
round two was simply exceptional we saw
two the most wonderful games that i ever
had the privilege of calling peter and i
can't wait for today please uh do the
honors of where
we're standing
absolutely the standings are as follows
as you see on your screen we have two
leaders uh yanni bonnie who beautiful
yesterday in one of those stunning games
yasser referenced
and the american wesley saw who won his
game against shakir yamamijarov
yesterday then we have six players who
made two draws so far and two people who
have drawn one and lost one
uh
bringing up the rear and our format
peter the format is
uh a ten player double uh not a double a
single
single round robin 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves as for the time control
with 30 minutes for the rest of the game
after that and a 30 second increment
starting from move one no drawer no draw
offers allowed at any point and you get
one point for a win half a point for a
draw and we award you no points for a
loss and we're in round three of our
schedule yeah the remaining schedule is
as follows we will have three more
rounds until the res day on tuesday may
the 10th and then four more rounds with
potential playoffs on saturday if they
are required
and alejandra you're in studio with us
good to see you my friend
and uh tell us about the players who are
also candidates what a pleasure to be
here with you guys early morning in st
louis but in bucharest we're almost
ready for the action four of the players
in this tournament are using bucharest
as a bit of a training ground as they
have a huge commitment coming up next
month in madrid four of the participants
of this tournament are going to be in
the candidates tournament of course
remember the winner of that event will
be challenging magnus carlsen or
hopefully magnus carlsen for the world
championship match and you can see the
players there richard report and ali
reservoir will be making their first
appearance in the candidates in the
coming months but we have a couple of
veterans jane pomnyacci he was
he went to the 2021 2021 2020 2021
candidates a very long tournament there
he won it
he a lot of people said he was benefited
by the fact that that tournament was cut
in half started off very well in the
first half and just squeaked through on
the second won the tournament with a
round to spare but of course there's
also fabiano carana who's played the
candidates three times going for his
fourth one we have fifty percent of the
field here in bucharest i'm excited to
see how they do against each other yan
started off blistering by defeating ali
reza purusha with the black pieces that
suddenly certainly sets the tone for the
coming tournament but let's take a look
at what we have coming up for today as
we join our friends in bucharest
christian and anastasia
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day three of the 2022 super
bad chess classic from location here in
bucharest romania to give you all the
updates and call all the action i'm your
host grand master christian hirola and
i'm joined by my brilliant co-host
woman's grandmaster anastasia carlo vich
anastasia yesterday we had an amazing
day filled with excitement what do you
have your eyes set on for today yeah
it's been a great day yesterday and i'm
looking forward for another round um i
just noticed that none of the candidates
will be playing uh against each other
today so they can forget a little bit
about the preparation against each other
and focus on the and just purchase you
know and also i'm really looking forward
for the game between alireza perugia and
levonaranyan
lewand is the most experienced player
and le reza ferruga is the youngest one
they have played only two times in
classical games and both games finish in
the draw i'm wondering if today will be
the decisive game for them it's
definitely a clash of generation in that
one and that will be fire on the board
for sure one game that i'm definitely
having my eyes on is the big clash
between richie report and the young
romanian superstar
that one is going to be a clash of
styles in my opinion also these two
players have never met in classical
chess they have absolutely no
information about the other player at
least no face-to-face information now
why say it's a clash of styles because
bogdan daniel there is a player that
relies very much on his opening
preparation and generally punishes his
opponents if they stray away from the
main lines of theory now on the other
hand richie rapport is a player true to
his style through to his artistic
ingenuous style this is going to be a
clash that is going to be fire on the
board as well very very exciting games
coming up today guys how about
yourselves
well thank you anastasia thank you
christian let's take a look at all the
parents peter absolutely let's bring up
the pairings for today's round
uh our leaders are playing respectively
wesley is black against fabiano caruana
in an
all-american clash and yandy pomnishi is
white against yet another american
player in yar dominguez we also have a
game between uh mbl and shakira manjarov
two players who know each other
exceedingly well and then the two games
which i agree are very very exciting the
the ones pointed out by our colleagues
in romania uh levon is white against
alireza should be a fantastic game
and then the game between uh richard
rapport and bogdan dayek in which we see
richie play with the white pieces for
the first time in this tournament he's
had two blacks so far
and what are they playing for peter
and here you have the uh the prize fund
on on your screen uh there's a cool 100
000 up top for the winner and if you win
the tournament in uh classical you get
13 gct points and if you have to play
tie breaks you only get 12.
and a very nice spread of
prizes all the way down to 10.5 for 10th
and the total price fund is about 350.
yeah very nice figure of a hundred
thousand and of course the grand chess
tour has all of these events so the
players who build up their grandchester
points
uh gain uh
an extra at the end of the tournament
absolutely at the end of the tour bonus
money by having the most gct points
now yesterday
this guy
i mean we don't know how he survived
shaq doesn't know how he survived what
are we expecting first white i think he
knows how he survived yeah
we were discussing it
after the round yesterday the the three
of us and we came to the conclusion that
this was definitely one of the
perhaps rare occurrences where you
really really wanted to have it to have
it be a double press conference exactly
to have both of them there at the at the
screen explaining what they saw and what
they didn't see and how they felt about
their positions because yeah that was
there was a game there was an
unbelievable mess uh which is so it does
happen sometimes but it was also apart
from i would say dodgy opening choices
extremely well played by both players
that was the thing even though it
appeared like there was this plethora of
choices
in fact
the accuracy
of the players was really extraordinary
consid considering the amount of things
he had they had to wait away and assess
yeah it was it was a remarkably uh
accurate and and precise game which uh
honestly i'm still
in awe of what they achieved then and
then of course alejandro was so
hilarious when shaq came and expressed
his point of view because then he was
you could see this dawning uh
coming like
i wasn't winning i wasn't
it was just incredible i think for us as
well to understand that the position
wasn't winning but
in our eyes it was just crushing
by the way we have a special guest who
is going to be making the opening first
move
i think it's
daniel jenga yeah we
believe it's uh
e2e4
and uh yeah he is the uh
i believe the director of the romanian
opera so uh very
very nice to have
the the art world
joining us and joining us here or on
stage in the uh mvl suggesting he will
open suggesting he will open with the
pawn even though but he took it back
quickly he took it back quickly and also
you know as we have seen yesterday with
him not playing the grunfeld and opting
for the queen's gambit except he's also
been straying away from he's been a 1e4
player his entire life but recently
uh to
some bafflement honestly he has been uh
he's been you know dipping his stone in
differing waters but yeah
we'll see what what happens today
and here we have a another
and richard suggesting one knight c3
which is uh
a shout out to a friend of the stream no
no it's not 1v3 okay i was going to say
i was going to say it's a tribute to
lawrence trent but maybe maybe it is
the romani empire is very very happy
about knight c3 he was like very
enthusiastic he was happy about 93 but
then he said d3 was happier
he went he went even even happier
nice now uh even though we have only had
two victories from the first two rounds
i just feel peter that the games
themselves the content of the games and
the draws have been incredibly well
fought yeah we've had very very few
very very few
you know quote-unquote quiet games
perhaps the game uh wesley played
against mvl yesterday was
on the quieter side and even that one
featured you know some things were left
uh unshown on the board but when nvl
came into the romanian studio to show
some lines even that seemingly very dry
game could have
uh could have been quite interesting if
it continued but uh yeah
most of the draws i would say were
extremely extremely combative and uh and
featured some very interesting game now
anastasia in particular
uh said levonaronian
versus ali reza is a game she's watching
even though lavone ironian is not a
candidate maybe it's sort of like this
is a moment for lavonne to say you know
young man
i should be in the candidates and i'm
going to show you exactly why what do
you think about this aliyah it's hard to
believe on is not in the candidates he
has played six times wow incredible
veteran of these tournaments and he
basically just missed out on this one as
well right exactly
and as
christian said this is a classic clash
of generations as we have 39 year old
lavon hard to believe he's 39 years old
but he has been in the world's top
for 20 years
for a very very long time yeah and uh
he's open i was uh i was temporarily
rendered speechless by by you know i've
been hypnotized by watching him chewing
and i think we have a c4 c6
now
instead of the e6 d5 that
ali reza played against fabiano yeah
already switching things up from from
round one and
it's hard to say whether
specifically what alireza did against
fabi prompted levon played to play one
c4 he's a he's been an english player
all his life it's it's very much his
repertoire moves so
i don't think he will be you know
shocked by 1c6 or horribly disappointed
by it either i mean
now wesley so he has a very big
challenge in front of him today as he is
leading the tournament co-leader but
he's defending the black pieces against
fabiano fabi opened d4 i mean again the
players are
you know two-handed ambidextrous they
can play e4 d4 and we have a
catalan on the board with g2 g3 an
opening that actually wesley really
enjoys playing as white himself yeah uh
but i think most most top players by
this point have at least attempted to to
include catalan into the in in their
repertoire because
it's a way to avoid the sort of the rock
rock solid things that people do against
the non-catalan in this position like if
you play knight c3 uh the vienna and the
regards in uh
if we even if we sort of dunk out the
the
qgd
there's plenty of options here but
specifically the vienna and there goes
in uh
as it currently stands offer
black a very very good chance of
equalizing uh by force so to speak
because play becomes extremely concrete
and uh
potentially solvable in uh in some cases
whereas
uh the catalan does i think offer you uh
or at least is supposed to offer you
more of a chance not of an advantage
necessarily but of a game where your
opponent will actually have to start
playing at some point there will be play
um alejandra if i can pick you your your
brain for my moment
first of all if you were on the black
side of the catalan do you like to play
the catalan
open with d5 take c4 or do you like to
play a closed variation of the catalan
actually with the black pieces for some
reason during my career almost nobody
played catalan everybody was playing the
knight c3 variations it's just absolute
coincidence but i i've studied both
bishop e7 of course the more traditional
variation i never knew what was wrong
with it right it felt that a lot of
people were taking on c4 early they were
playing this a6 knight c6 stuff that
became extremely sharp there was a lot
of fun games on the variation but i
always thought bishop b7 just worked you
know
b7 castle take on c4 it was a recipe
that's been around for a long time and i
always felt it held quite well if not
comfortably so we'll see what we have in
on the board and actually fabi plays
this early move uh queen a4 which is s8
before a few times i don't uh think that
theoretically it's the most challenging
way of playing against the setup of the
catalan queen c2 of course is the main
line but it's worked out for fabi he's
actually beaten a few good players in
this variation before it can't be a
surprise for
wesley because he has faced it before i
believe he's faced it against favi
himself
uh in a in a
tie break here in st louis but i'm
trying to remember exactly what game
that was
uh 2018 right i'm not entirely sure i
have a feeling this may have happened
yeah but uh i've uh recently had ted on
occasion to like listen to lectures on
this topic because i
uh i was uh covering the world
championship where catelyn was
a feature between magnus and uh
and jan obviously last year and uh
uh my co-hosts uh
taught me some things about this but the
reason queen a4 is chosen these days at
least a potential reason why queen a4 is
chosen these days over the much more
usually
is the emergence of the line
specifically queen c2b5
and then uh after a4
at one point it was very much on vogue
to play b5 before here and those
positions became a hot topic of
discussion but since then they've
discovered this idea of playing bishop
b7 here which is amazing movement yeah
we should be seven eight xb5 a6 right
and uh yeah it looks like black's uh
structure is being destroyed but and it
isn't legitimate it is a legitimate pawn
sacrifice blood doesn't regain the pawn
because after b takes a6 we take with
the knight not uh not the bishop uh but
the the peace activity black acquires
after queen takes e4 and i believe
bishop d5
as i understand it currently black is
holding this reasonably comfortably even
i would suggest uh in terms of uh
you know the current the the current
situation in in practice
and
queen a4 i think is aimed squarely at
not allowing any of this but what it
does allow in comparison with quincy two
is exactly the move that wesley played
because if you play queen c2a6
uh white at least has the option of
playing a2a4 here as opposed to queen
and i think it has become the main move
here because the queen takes c4 lines
are
supposedly not very much
but have you if you play queen a4 you
take this option away from you so you
will have to play the position that
yasser has on your screen right now you
will have to you will have to take on c4
go quincy to
bishop b7 and go from here
and uh once again i'm not a catalan
player with either color i i dabbled in
it maybe 15 years ago but we didn't know
much then and definitely don't know
anything now
but in my understanding that's just not
not a lot at all and and wesley as a
catalan player himself he probably
should have a pretty decent idea exactly
why this isn't supposed to be anything
at all right
and the lifetime between these two
players
wins three losses that's so close that's
a lot of draw that is a lot yeah i mean
what separates them is something
incredibly incredibly narrow
wow one one win between them and by the
way this was um
gosh you go back to the 80s you have
guenis asanko
anatoly karpov and others that were
blazing trails in this particular
variation in the catalan and bishop d2
was the go-to move
yeah and the move i liked a lot was
bishop f4 i i played that uh against uh
karpov and walter brown and others but
bishop d2 has a very intriguing idea and
it's a it's a kind of a funny one white
is trying to prevent c7 absolutely
that's what it's all about now the fight
is over c7 c5 black wants to play knight
d7 c7 c5 and away you go once you get in
c5 you're completely fine in most cases
and maybe even sometimes even a little
bit better absolutely and what was the
purpose behind bishop d2 no kidding the
purpose was to play the move bishop a4
and simply depend this pawn prevent it
from from going to c5 and in some cases
following up with even
yeah and doing it on a5 by playing with
b2b4 which really does look
stunningly stupid but isn't exactly
exactly it really isn't so bishop d2
again where we're in the dusty parts of
the library
what do you have for us alejandro some
of the other games i was just going
around different games we will have a
couple clash of styles in the game
between maxim and shock we have a karo
khan e4 c6 and maxim very often plays
this setup with both knights being
developed instead of the usual the or
more common i would say move d4 and
after takes takes knight f6 queen e2
um
we have a position which i actually saw
richard rapport win win once in a live
tournament because his opponent win
knight bd7
and that was made on d6 i actually saw
him do this once which is kind of funny
but we have this variation where knight
takes queen takes and the move queen a5
i don't know this variation very well i
know that most people are trying to
exchange the queens here with the move
queen d5
immediately challenging the queen in the
center and it's become some sort of hot
topic both the move queen f4 and queen
h4 have been seen in this position but
the move queen a5 i don't know very well
maxine seems to be thinking a little bit
about it as well um it's not completely
unknown to me but
i don't think that it's considered to be
the main line right now another clash of
interesting styles we have this game
that is rushing down the theoretical
board wow this is the game between uh
jane pognachi and linear dominguez
lanier is using the petrov defense
something that's become more and more
and more common uh already enjoyed a
surge of popularity but here we have
this very similar variation to what we
have earlier in the tournament
with
a knight c3 the doubling of the pawns on
the queen side in order to gain
development but instead of taking on e5
like dak did against nepali we have the
move bishop d6 which goes into a
completely different variation and they
are just blitzing out this variation c5
queen f3 i don't exactly know this
position but apparently they are
following a game of van forest and
friedman c4 bishop f5 knight takes e5
takes rook e8 this is
apparently both of their books because
they are just blitzing all of these
moves out let me just get to the
position that we have on the board right
now because this is already yeah this is
already on the board
we're in an end game we're in an end
game uh white is currently up a pawn but
he has problems with the c5 the c5 pawns
as well as some problems with the back
rank the computer's saying there's a
very slight edge for the white pieces i
have the feeling that dominguez believes
that this is a drawn end game and he can
draw it by force
but we're going to have to wait and see
a couple of more moves to determine if
that's completely true for now it is an
extra pawn for the white side probably
not an easy one to convert but these
guys are just
zooming through this game exactly they
sure are
and i'd like to draw our attention peter
to the game uh between lavonna roni and
ali reza i was uh present
in vikranze ages ago
when this very topical variation at that
time of the slav appeared between gary
kasparov from the white side and
alexander morizovich on the black side
and morozevich
in this very well-known position you go
back to the 1935 world championship
match between alekhine and max irva uh
f7 f6 but g5 appeared and
gary went into this think tank yeah and
just spent like 50 minutes and he just
like
worked it out worked it out calculated
calculated calculated
and
won over the board
and gary was
and still is not not bad at chess yeah
it was just a it was an amazing feat and
what gary played
ended up becoming the main line main
line which was also
rather extraordinary
and
it was like one of the games for the
aegis queen c2 on the board yeah and
this is definitely one of the more
recognizable contributions of alexander
marazzevic to
opening theory uh among with
along with all of the uh all of the
french ideas he's had i think this this
particular slav uh most people will
probably call it the the morozevich
variation exactly it's most deserving
yeah and absolutely yeah without him
he not only was he was he the first one
to play it he also continued developing
the theory of it and it very much
deservedly bears his name i don't
particularly know uh the current uh the
current state of it to be honest uh it
it sort of disappeared from top
tournament practice at some point people
were playing it it was all the rage for
a while and then it kind of what is the
uh current uh
theory uh top theory uh ali alejandro
you've got your database there
it's just a little bit out of fashion uh
the moose g takes f4 knight takes f5 are
definitely the main line black always
castles in this position and queen c2 is
by far the main move but here actually
black's main source of counter play
usually starts with a move knight c5 in
this position and black
white usually castles pawn takes g3 h
takes g3 and you can see there's a bunch
of games here on my right side and black
has tried to move a5 i think mainly just
preventing the move b4 from the white
side and there's a ton of games from
this position hundreds uh black obtain
the
opposite color bishops you could argue
that h5h4 looks like a source of counter
play but actually people figured out
that it doesn't do very much with the
knight on f5 you can't easily push this
button all the way to h4 you know you
would love to a lot of times white goes
rook fd1 and black actually has to deal
with white's threads first it goes to a
complex game but instead of that uh here
alireza plays them with king b8 it has
been seen before quite a few times
morozevich himself played it in 2005
against elianov there's a game of wonhao
nakamura where white castled as well so
king v8 a little bit of a wrinkle
compared to the usual knight c5
the idea is maybe the knight c5
stops
the bishop on f8 from protecting the b
b4 square so
you don't
maybe you don't have to play the move a7
a5 uh
i think my suggestion would be
simply that uh
king b8 will probably be necessary at
some point in the game like you i'm sure
you know this uh
this feeling that like if you if you if
you castle queenside until you have
played king b1 with white or king b8
with black there's this each right you
exactly you feel that i agree yeah you
haven't completed castling yet somehow
and and
generally the concept of
making the necessary moves first and
then making the optional ones later is a
very valid one but
all of this is generalities this is a
very very concrete position and there
must be a concrete reason why why you
start with king b8 overnight c5 and i
suggest i even know what that concrete
reason is and that would be
computer tells you to
come here
and uh what does the computer tell us to
do after the move king b8 uh alejandro
the kimber after king b the computer
actually wants to take on f4 it also yes
but yes
that's what i wanted to ask you could
also just castle there's a big
difference with the line knight c5 and
king b8 knight c5 is an active
developing move and the knight is very
well placed there so after you take on
f4 in this position you have the move
knight c4 rook is coming to d2 the queen
is taking on f4 everything kind of falls
apart for the white side the difference
is that with the king on b8 and the
knight on d7 when i take and go knight
c4 first of all there is no rook d2
problems in this position and the knight
on c5 is not actually hitting this uh
position on d3 so i could go e3 and the
other variation of course with the king
on state and the knight c5 you have this
ugly check on d3 and white's position
basically collapses but that's going to
take you a full turn you have to go
knight c5 here you don't want to castle
into the open file and rook d2 is coming
as well but you could play rook d1 and
we have had a few games from this
position where black tries to regain the
pawn quickly by taking on d1 and going
queen a5 but it just goes down the
theoretical channels uh that would be
the main difference between knight c5
and king b8 is the ability to take on f4
now let's see if levon does it you don't
have to take on f4 you could just castle
you could even consider the move rook d1
but uh the conley has been laid down you
could take on f4 and try we'll we'll see
what happens uh it's
they played twice before
two draws as we mentioned earlier in the
program let's see if this is the
decisive
yeah not not too many uh games between
them but again
clash of generations yeah theirs are
still still still young
would you uh grab the pawn here if you
were watching i've been i've been eyeing
it since since i talking king ba because
i wasn't quite sure actually even what
what the response is because my i
thought you know has to be knight g6 to
win a tempo but then after 82 e3 there
really isn't very much uh very much of
initiative for
uh especially as the knight on g6 is a
really kind of
burdened exactly yeah i was i was
slightly confused by this but yeah
knight c49c5 does make does make a lot
more sense exactly
putting knights on much more active
squares e3 probably still required
because you can't really give the pawn
on a fallback so easily right anyway in
this position um alejandra said you
don't want to castle castle into it so
to speak i think the problem with
castles is not necessarily even rook g8
i think it's just rook d2 is extremely
awkward exactly because we don't really
have good squares for uh for the queen
with all the uh night moves coming in
exactly so preventing preventing uh
priority it's just a priority yeah
exactly which is where rook given comes
in exactly and uh
well i mean uh
this this looks to be
a very intriguing clash let's uh check
in on the game of shaq i am just a
little curious uh
no no that's not shack we haven't seen
this one yet so maybe we should stop
here and show the viewers what's going
on in the game between uh richard and uh
bogdan uh this is a nimzo but a kind of
a quietish with e39 ge2 which is
something people of course have been
doing for a long long time but it's not
supposed to be
all that
all that ambitious and there's a number
of things you can do in response c6
being one of them but not the most
popular one
i think uh when i looked at these
positions we couldn't really find
anything
at all exciting about the g5
simply g5 lines d5 let's say a3 we go
back to either g6 or e7
and both moves in my opinion
are eminently playable for blind you can
go knight f4 immediately you can go cd5
and hope for e takes d5 and go knight
there and i know this from um many of uh
sami ruschevsky's game sammy reshefsky
being a giant of american chess but
c7 c6 yeah the move does exist and uh
the idea here of course is to play g5 uh
preserving the option of recapturing on
d5 with the c pawn if you want and also
as we are actually seeing in the game
giving the bishop on before an
alternative route to escape y a5 to c7
and it does sort of prompt c4 c5 i think
it's a very logical move here i think
i've actually looked at this there's
there are some incredibly sharp lines
here potentially if you go before bishop
c7 you are kind of committed i think if
you played before to playing e4 here
to which black i think replies with d5
e5 and then i think knight
the four-part
it's a very very wild position the
knight goes somewhere and then you get
all kinds of pawn breaks you get f6 97
very often black will be actually aiming
to sacrifice a piece on e5 if you meet
f6 with a four this is a very very sharp
position which i i think we looked at
this when i was preparing for the london
candidates which obviously is a long
time ago and things have changed but
yeah this is a very exciting
choice that
richie chose not to
not to go for instead he he went with
c4c5 uh trying to change the structure a
little bit uh of course he plays e5 to
take on passang here uh queen takes
before and somewhat interestingly the
bishop went to b6 and not to c7
alejandro
what's uh what's going on yeah like why
why isn't why isn't the bishop on c7
here well he's played this before so he
doesn't really have to guess things we
are still following a game that dak
himself played against gupta a few years
ago actually uh grand master gupta won
that game with the wide pieces he's
played bishop b6 before the move bishop
c7 is the more common one though there
is a game between wesley saw and hikaru
nakamura where hikaru went bishop c7 won
that one i think it was a rapid and
blitz but i have to double check um
bishop e6 seems to be the way that dak
likes to handle this position in my
point of view the bishop on c7 is more
logical the only advantage i see with
the bishop on b6 is that perhaps an e5
break would come with a little bit more
attacking on d4 but by all means i
thought the moon c6 was to put the
bishop on c7 and hopefully white castles
doesn't realize it's checkmate on h2
i'm not really sure why you can give a
smothered mate you can get on h2 i just
never know right right i'm a little
confused about the move bishop v6 it's
the engines don't think there's any real
difference between the moves as usual
the engines just think every move is
playable but logically speaking i like
the move bishop c7 a little bit more but
dak has had his analysis
he definitely trusts on what he has
studied and prefers to move bishop v6
over the more normal one just want to
check in really quickly on uh this
this theoretical battle
same same structure yeah we're to have
this for a while i think as the players
finally slowed down between yane pognach
and linear dominguez still an extra pawn
for white we just see the move a4
peter what do you think are the actual
winning chances for white in this
position i sort of trust linear on this
uh i would be worried here with black if
i didn't know any like if if you just
gave me this position with no
no knowledge of what the clock says no
knowledge of the names of the players
obviously there are drawing chances
there are always drawing chances in
these types of heavy uh heavy psn games
but to me uh apart from the extra point
the obvious
white having more pawns than black it's
the uh you know relative king safety
here is what worries me uh for falling
here because
the fact that the extra pawn is on the
king's side and the black king on h8 if
white somehow manages to activate that
rook on a1
and it comes into play the king on h8
will will start feeling very very shaky
and and this is why the queen is so
important taking away all of the squares
like the g1 and the e1 squares are very
well controlled uh the queen endings
might be drawn
but i think you hate to play them uh
like i've been i've been looking at this
and thinking could the plan be to i
don't know make one more a moving
preparation of b7 b6 or something and
then i should just give a check from d1
and say i am not going to lose this
queen ending
but i but i think nobody really plays
like this i think uh
the torture that's ahead of you uh as
black in that queen ending is just so
unattractive that
you probably don't want to do that
but then what's the plan because you
can't really attack anything quinji ii
uh
maybe q2 is the way to try to to attack
some material here apart from the move
queen e3d2 i don't see a single active
move that does anything rook d2
uh i'm worried about the idea of leaving
the back rank i also don't don't like
allowing any kind of potential checks
and the c2 pawn doesn't seem worth it
all that night all that much necessarily
f2 is well protected so
uh that would be like my assessment if i
knew absolutely nothing about this
position i just saw it for the first
time but with lanier absolutely blitzing
into it right and lanier is you know one
of the premier theoreticians of our age
he works very very diligently on chess
he knows his stuff uh i'm pretty sure
he's not only seen the evaluation on his
string he probably also clicked around
trying to figure and and figured out you
know what to aim for yeah which which
pieces to trade which which positions
are easily easily holdable which
positions are going to be a torture and
so on so
i mean from jan's viewpoint i understand
why he's also even if he knows this is
holdable
he clearly has a very easy positive free
role here right you know if he doesn't
win he doesn't win he but he will be the
one the only one with winning chances so
why not just play this
uh but for the year yeah we will see the
fact that he started thinking after
after h3 and a4 is a bit worrying and
their lifetime score is very close very
close within favor of veneer very
surprising that the challenger previous
challenger nippo
trails
too considering amano games
let me just play the devil's advocate
for a moment with you there peter
because
uh it is so very difficult the the pawn
structure on the queen side it's not
like it's a an extra pawn let's say i
just play b7 b6 just give me one move
and i'll i'll tell you what i'm doing
next i wonder if i should play five i'm
gonna die i'm very happy uh
yeah
now this probably is a draw yeah an nba
in the end yeah yeah because this is
where i really wanna go with this i
wanna to induce well i want to play g3
here i don't i'm playing if you're going
to play g3 i'm going to go queen
d2 i'm trying to trying to get you to
play let me just show you what i'm
trying to get you to do is f4 and takes
that was the whole point that i did but
you could play ba in the previous movie
yeah i think i think you're absolutely
right a5 a5 would have been a useful
move for white if not for the fact that
rookie one check exists exactly um
so
yeah i mean
to me b6 is by far the most natural move
in the position and i'm i'm wondering
what else in year is considering there
perhaps it is rook d2
um because
my original my original skepticism maybe
was slightly overstated because the c2
pawn is not that bad like if we get to
pick up the opponency too i think we're
reasonably happy because we're not
giving up control over the g-file one
thing that would worry me about leaving
the back rank would be to leave one of
the
large files open for the rook on a1 but
we're not doing that well for for me i i
like what you said at the very start
which is watch out
and now we go bishop watch out for the
back rank i i i am patrolling
this um how do you say rookie five now
is a very very big threat well you still
have queenie one check i must say it's
unfortunately yeah
probably just holds on the spot right
exactly unfortunately for me uh
that does appear to hold on the spot i
have to probably
place well g3
it's awkward right yeah it is uh rook d2
might be uh just the way to go
catch up for us alejandro on uh
this position please on this position b6
the engines think is definitely the best
move i was playing around with the move
rook d2 but it doesn't fully equalize it
does have the issue of the move a5 wow
and after rook takes c2 this kg little
move rook b1 you're attacking b7 it's
not a surprise you don't have that many
good ways to defend it you could take on
c3 but that just loses because rook
takes b7 and you guys finally mentioned
the problem of the king on h8 is much
greater than the problems of the king on
g1 once the rook reaches the back right
that's game over i was hoping to play
queen d3 there after obi-wan that's what
why i thought this was playable queen d3
here has the issue of queen f8 champions
and rook b7 yeah and rook b7 and i don't
think you have anything yeah the queen
covers d6 exactly this is the point i
missed that i don't have queen d126 here
okay yeah
you don't have queen d6 in this position
there's no checks and the initiative
fails but there's still one more try for
black in this position and this one
could be a little tempting from far away
you could go rook b wait did i miss him
if a5 takes c2 rook b1 rook b2 there you
go uh rook takes queen takes and the
game kind of keeps going you could go uh
check on c8 king h7 you take on c4 i
take on
this is a draw though queen a5
pick up this one you pick up this one i
pick up this one you pick up this one
and the only question is do you want to
play the same game as black
it is a draw it's theoretically a draw i
i guess you lose it once every i don't
know 10 games yeah i think i think you
go for this having gone for the entire
line to begin with i think you'd take
three against two you could but the
question also could simply be what is
white's next move because you just
played a4 with the idea of a5 it's not
strengthening your position in any other
way the pawn is not really getting
captured uh differently on a2 that is on
an e4 it got gets picked up pretty much
the same way so why not throw in the
move b6 exactly and then go for some
kind of rook d2s and equalizing the rook
is not penetrating anywhere on the first
rank to the last one all of this is
controlled the beast file is now shut uh
thanks to the b6 move and of course if
you go a5 now i can do almost all of the
same things take on a5 as you mentioned
and that will be um completely equal so
i think that the move rook d2 is enough
for equality maybe quality is not the
correct way you're not for a draw yeah
but
b6 might just be the cleaner way to do
it
thank you for that and i just picked up
on the game of wesley so again uh wesley
and ian our co-leaders fabi uh
on the white side of a catalan and again
this very very old theoretical dispute
in my test library i might say my
notebooks uh we could look at some stuff
bishop d2 bishop e4
and
this was played very often too bishop e4
crazily enough sometimes they just
dropped right back but the follow-up is
kind of kind of new and i think this is
what is what is supposed to be the
quote-unquote solution to the bishop d2
line of the catalan at least in my
understanding i think at some point and
once again i think i think we have to
thank uh
vladimir kramnik for this uh people have
realized you can play c6 with the
intention of eventually replying to
knight c3 was uh with the uh
retreat to the g6 square
and c6 very efficiently solves the uh
potential problem of bishop a5 because
we are now controlling that square yep
uh and and black just wants to play
knight bg7 rook c8 and c5 uh having gone
uh with the bishop outside the pawn
chain and uh
efficiently sort of negotiates much of
the ideas that lie behind
bishop d2 a4 i'm not so sure i've seen
very much here i once again not not a
catalan specialist to take everything i
say about this opening with a
with a
bag of salt yeah a bag of salt yeah and
uh before it was an interesting reply i
don't think it was uh forced but then
again taking away the c3 square and the
a3 square from the knight on b1 cannot
really be all that unattractive
so for me i just uh
i'm not serious
i'm not quite sure that i would
i i i would want to part with the pawn
on d4 but i really need to no i but i
need to make room for my knife i really
want to ask you like if i go before
which i think is a move i would have
made in this position kind of
automatically do you actually take one
of three here with black
let's just see it i mean it looks like
it looks unplayable to me rook g192c4 it
just looks unplayable to me
i don't know
you know i i i kind of never ever do
this to myself because the knight ends
up
some some very nice games were won in
these types of structures there was in
particular the game i think a hugely
instructive game was won by alexander
grisham against hikaru
i can't remember exactly where
it yeah maybe possibly here actually
yeah here i thought it was here but even
the candidates yeah um yeah okay i need
your attention for a second because we
do have a development in one of the
games this is levon against perugia and
we left it off here after the move king
b8
takes on f4 happened and the move we
expected knight c4 and as i had
mentioned e3 knight c5 had been played
before there's a wong hao nakamura game
there's other good games in this
position hare krishna played this with
white against marcus roger from austria
rook d1 and every game here has followed
like this rook takes knight takes queen
a5 check every game follows like this
everybody here has played the move
knight c3 and lavon
he spent a little bit of time he's
thought about it and he said why should
i play knight c3
i'm gonna go king e2
this is very confusing because
it's a confusing move because while the
king is now in the center
it's not going gonna go easily back into
hiding you can't really castle in many
of these positions and it tactically has
a problem now of course if you take on
a4 take on a4 take on a4 oops first of
all i don't know why you're trading
queens when this guy's king is now on e2
but the problem is that b3 just picks up
a knight uh you don't have the move
knight t3 check this knight is covering
and you just lose one of them clear but
after the move king e2 there's the move
queen a6 which not only is very logical
because you defend the knight at the
same time that you threaten some kind of
discovery uh with it so you're
immediately targeting kind of forces
king of three no it actually forces the
move king f3 there is no other move if
you go back to e1 not only could i make
a draw but i can just take on a4 with
one of the knights this king is a bit
stuck this move bishop b4 check is
coming as a huge problem
the bottom b2 needs to defend so you
don't have to move knight c3 so this is
already according to the engine lost
not not even close right so you do have
to go uh queen a6 king
king a6 king f3 but at this point the
engine says well thank you for your king
on f3 it's very awkward you could take
on a4 now uh
take stakes and the bottom b2 is
currently hanging you can also have
moves like rook g8 you're going to start
advancing this majority and you don't
have the move b3 like you had in the
previous line because i force your king
to f3 and this allows knight d2 check
picking up the pawn on the next move so
yeah the engine is giving a pretty
significant advantage to aliresa already
if he finds the move queen a6 king f3
and queen takes a for the second i was i
was wondering about queen a16 f3 and
being a you know an
incorrigible romantic that i am king of
three knight g3 was kind of drawing my
eye but i guess we don't have threats
right we just
it's a it's a cute move but it doesn't
really do very much the kingdom of three
is safe enough and we don't have actual
checks to threaten i didn't expect 93 to
make it a plus five position
but so much for romance i mean that's a
you could get a slap in the face after
uh yeah the edges the engines do say
this is the only way for our laressa to
get an advantage is queen a6 and the
follow-up queen takes a4 there are other
tries especially considering that the
king is on f3 so black does have several
ways of playing where he could obtain
compensation for his pawn but for a
clear advantage this is the only way
queen takes a4 that just
throws down the gauntlet as far as the
challenge my first thought was that
maybe white was going to avoid
trading queens after queen takes a
particularly good square you can play
queen c3 but you're just forcing black
to make a move that he wants to play
anyway anyway no yeah unfortunately i
don't have some brilliant follow-up of
queen
check on e5 but
it's
it's it's a dodgy position absolutely i
mean i don't feel uh that good
uh with white but i'm not sure if i feel
that good with black either
okay i think you do pick black here
because you you have the more active
pieces which are difficult to attack and
there's uh all kinds of tactical
shenanigans which might which might
start happening here
like if the knight from c4 jumps
somewhere there will be queen e4 threats
and so on exactly you have to you have
to be very careful here with white to me
the evaluation of the position is
surprising but quincy three rook g8
minus five
minus five yeah the game's over wow
actually the best move according to the
engine is king e2
just giving up the [ __ ] just give up
the bishop otherwise you you get more
mated
you get more made you get more mated
yeah like okay this show is a mate i
mean i just i don't even see the mate
threat yeah
i think of the bishop g7 you kind of oh
well bishop g7 i've just helped
my opponent a lot yeah the funny thing
is it's not easy to make a move that
doesn't help you okay sorry rookie one
uh rookie one i think
without looking at an engine that it's
knight b3
night boy three yeah
oh boy three oh boy
oh boy three
yeah this doesn't look good
i mean it doesn't it really does not
doesn't look good yeah
now this is not a pleasant way of
spending the morning so queen a6 i just
want to say a4
i just want to say it's uh very unusual
for yvonne to to do this to himself
because uh
i mean he does like uh i mean he enjoys
non-standard positions and i my eye was
also drawn to the movie too because uh
you know the knight on c4 continues
hanging you seemingly are forcing some
concessions here but
uh
he also is a very very clean calculator
and uh i mean it's difficult to me miss
queen a6 you could maybe miss queen
takes a4 but
once you get the queen a6 king of three
just how happy are you with your
position in general yeah
i think you're taking it too
too too many risk uh
by the way we when we talk about really
great opening players too uh for me
lavon aronian his his openings are
outstanding uh he
especially his e5 is black e4 e5 uh
positions he knows so far so well so in
and out i i wanted to turn uh some time
ago i'm a car con player so forgive me
in advance and if you're going to play
this variation as white i always thought
that queen d5
was the way to go so i'm just kind of
curious as to what happened after queen
a5 of course the whole idea behind queen
a5 is you want to protect the f5 square
and develop your bishop with a tempo
assume this came quickly c2 c3 somewhat
quickly not not instantaneously and uh
i mean having played c3 of course you
expect mvl to play d4 but his next move
is yeah i kind of had to look at the
screen
well he wants to play knight c4 and then
queen g3 or the other way around
because obviously b7 now will force us
to commit to a square and i think the
square is quite clear the g3
and then we play knight c4 and we've
taken away some squares from the black
queen i still don't really believe this
is anything much let's say i go queen d8
here and i start pushing for the c5
break
if you play 96 uh first of all i don't
think pawn grabbing will work very well
i think i should actually just play
bishop g6 here because yeah the
difference in development is starting to
become kind of really alarming queen b6
96 c5 here or something
there are a lot of pieces on the first
yeah
so yeah it it
you know
now that uh tom and the the rest of
these team gentlemen uh who uh so
fantastically produce our show have
included my fps into the language of
chess even though originally it was from
a different board game altogether
i do want to say that the you know c3
g490 knight c4 does look a little bit
fbsc here
what is the knight doing on c4 that
wasn't doing on f3 a strange maneuver
for
our eyes alejandro but but honestly
maybe white just didn't have anything uh
to begin with special yeah but okay i
mean i can imagine just you you just get
on with business right you should go
bishop but then nobody really like with
the bishop on five this these types of
cairos are you know you're super super
solid yeah black is just fine black will
develop place e5 and
things will
well well fair enough and the lifetime
result between these two players is
astonishingly in favor of shaq big time
that's a big-time problem for this year
two wins seven losses for the frenchman
against mamadiara of 19 draws but it's
always been a problematic matchup for
mvl and i don't think he has very much
with this move 92 he's just trying to
get a game
i actually played around with it a
little bit the move bishop e7 the
engines think it's okay
but just break in the center if you want
to play c5 do it while the iron's hot
knight f3 d2 uh doesn't really help
white's development right yeah
and then we drop back to c7 and then you
will you take advantage of the fact that
there is no queen g3 just yet yep knight
c4 queen c7 and bish before queen c6 is
a very solid square for the queen
another
advantage of having played c5 already is
giving us the square on c6 to
uh to jump to if required yeah
absolutely yeah i could very much c5
looks like a very good
counter
in the center
very very nice uh pardon me we haven't
uh uh
we're used to seeing this by the way
lanier
great opening theoretician blitzes out
his first 18 moves rather a la tempo and
then comes the 45 minute followed by the
20-minute thing i mean one thing isn't
enough you get the two long things
back-to-back and so that he gets into
time pressure by move 30 right alejandro
that's
i mean it doesn't really matter what the
opening is it feels that linear will be
in time pressure somehow or another
exactly exactly
um
in baghdad's game richard ricci's just
played the move knight e2
to
g3 and i think that's a
seems logical the the big question of
course is uh as alejandro was saying
bishop b6 is very much telegraphing that
e65 is coming because the only reason to
put it on a diagonal which is kind of
blocked by the white structure
is is to try to
try to blow that structure up and to
increase the pressure against it with
the pawn break in the center
and uh you know the two ways for white
to complete development in this position
are
93 which richard chose or exactly as the
asser is uh pointing out uh g3 bishop g2
with the intention of just recapturing
on d4 with the knight i think this is
where bishop music kind of shines
because uh you take on d4 and if you
take with the knight i'm quite happily
taking on d4 twice and playing 9b6b6
with a very comfortable yeah this is
completely unplayable end game probably
is slightly more playable but still i'm
probably preferring black there which is
why richie
eschewed g3 and instead played knight to
g3
maybe in order to be able to meet e5
with simply capturing or there is a
knight f5 there isn't yeah i'm trying to
figure out if there's something uh
something exciting here that you can go
for some kind of a sacrificial play with
knight f5 and then something or bishop
d3 and then something but
it feels like we're not developed enough
to start sacrificing passes honestly
so i i have a suspicion we might
actually just have to take on e5 and
play that end game i assume black takes
on d1 and then on e5 and not create the
xc5
and uh these are these are rare
actually legitimately rare footage of
people in the players lounge because
normally the player's lounge is sort of
off limits off limits to most everyone
apart from the players in the arbiter so
this is sort of like their relaxed room
they can go get themselves something to
drink to eat
nobody's talking to each other i mean
that's strictly forbidden of course but
they can look at the monitors and see
uh if it's their moves or not nobody's
talking because i'm not playing in this
tournament
well there used to be a smoker's lounge
now they don't even
now it's completely forbidden uh
in the playing hall or anywhere near um
uh i'm still uh
i'm still kind of liking richie's
position a little bit because
yeah after e5 what what are you guys
saying why can't i take on e5 right no
no no that was the ending that we were
just kidding with the night the knight
takes you what
yeah queen takes day one knight takes d1
ah
that is yeah that is important excuse me
and then uh suddenly whoops that bishop
on b2
94 actually does win the pawn back but
after e6 you're not going to be liking
your life all that much exactly exactly
uh this bishop on b2 to my eyes is
really radiating some intense energy
down this diagonal whereas don't think
the bishop on be6 is its equivalent uh
that kind of maybe puts the kibosh on e5
and that's why rook d8 was played by
bogdan
d david yeah and then you have the
option of e5d and just knight the xc5
protecting the queen on the sixth of the
road now i'm loving your ideas of knight
f5 and things like that
maybe
it's time to play bishop city oh
yeah uh e5 can be met by knight
specifically taking away the square of
the e6 square from the queen yeah
now it's starting to feel like things
are at least going in white's favor not
that bishop c4 is
the
automatic or anything like that just
feels like uh white has a more a greater
influence yeah
i'm wondering if you know simply because
of the the the lines that we're showing
and similar lines if maybe black
uh could switch it up a little bit and
go for a different pawn break starting
with a5
okay trying to provoke b5 and reply i
don't know if b5 is forced you can
definitely make an argument for queen b3
but at least if you play queen b3 i get
to trade some pieces on the queen side i
get to to offload some of the
some of the material i still don't know
if i equalize or not but uh i think
black should welcome in this position an
option of trades getting the a file off
the board
and if you play b5 instead which i think
is the default setting here trying to
keep the as much material as possible on
the board i want to make b5 with c5 and
try to undermine the white center in
this way in this way it's uh it's still
risky because
we still have this bunch of pieces on
the queen side which aren't in the game
which very much makes me want to start
sacrificing stuff just to prevent black
from developing properly i don't know
exactly how even the move d4g5 here is
maybe not entirely insane uh probably
doesn't work but i think there you i can
sort of explain the reasoning behind it
even though it will not work tactically
i can explain why i'm attracted to it
well because of these sleeping queen
side pieces yeah and also i would like
to have access to the f5 squares
eg595 at least gives me as some kind of
a
hope for a mating attack on the king
side with my
horowitz bishops very yeah very nice
we'll keep an eye on that one and let me
just go again back to the levon game for
a moment because this is uh
as alejandro has been explaining
there's a sequence of moves here that
really will put
white
to the test of fire queen a6
setting up uh potential discovered
uh checks
seems to
force pretty much force king king f3 and
then
and now queen takes a4 queen takes a4
and knight takes a4 there is the
the previously uh brilliant b2b3 winning
a piece is not so brilliant anymore you
get the feeling what probably saves the
game after king e2 here reestablishing
the threat of b3 and also preparing if
you take twice on b2 i do have the rugby
one count to play is that so clear
though peter there is clear no there is
a three that was uh
there's also knight a4
ah knight a4 is worrying me much more
actually
yeah before and then kingston
has taken a 20-minute thing
this critical yeah well that's three
connected
three connected pass bonds on the queen
side versus none that's what i call a
majority
that is very much very much a majority
then yeah a very nice majority so
that's
not the bailout we wanted yeah but then
the beats upon is just gone right and uh
like there is no there is no construct
constructive or
non-constructive way of protecting it
here right yeah yeah this is trouble
three against not i mean you will have i
mean the knight on the five is a very
beautiful piece the rook has
complex
is not very active just yet but
uh i mean
it's still going to be down upon and
three
connected passers on the queen side if
they start running they you know this
dispels trouble and i think alireza is
thinking simply because he is just
trying to figure out what he's missing
i'm pretty sure he's found queen a64 by
now and he is
and at that point his
his thinking is sort of twofold a he is
double checking uh whether he is missing
something and b i think after clean a6
king of three he can very much be
excused
uh
in
spending some time trying to investigate
whether he has something even stronger
than queen takes a four because the king
of three is awkward exactly exactly uh
yeah queen a4 is at least a good default
option if not if there's not something
even more attractive so looking good
there for ali reza let's just see uh
rook d8
b6 has been played by the beast took
half an hour to make it many yeah
yes exactly and again i uh
let's make a different a decent pass for
just a moment h4 i don't want to say
that if we wanted to play h4 we could
have done it on move 21. that is true it
could have already been there so
yeah
and we do have this check that uh yeah
g3 g3
this is the move that i had
really uh put a great deal of
i'm hitting everything
yeah it's extremely okay i was like
every time you bring this up i think
okay i will play king ju2 here you will
take on c3 and i will find a way to do
something but like what that something
is is apart from a perpetual exactly
i'm not entirely sure what that
something is exactly i think that's uh i
think that is the perpetual that's
coming here in this game
just feels to me like lanier has got
this
how do you make a draw if i just go like
g4 g5 g6
g4 g5 24
i guess yeah you can actually
i will take on h4 i think i don't think
i'm not allowed to take on h4 there
is it a mate
i don't think it's a mate no well g6 the
question is what we play against like
could you five check are we very
happy with that because the king is very
far away it has to be calculated right
they take a good king of three and then
but aren't i a pawn up in this ending
yes but
it's a challenge
it's a race are you sure
takes 16 d5 i think that one you
definitely lost six seven
six seven eight nine
and four and what do you do
one
two three four five six seven and four
so you definitely win
the race
with uh
with white
but let's uh jump over to bucharest and
a report from our team
there hello everyone
thank you yasser yes i just want to give
you guys a quick report about what's
happening in the playing hall as well as
what i feel the emotions are uh between
these players and i want to start with
the game between aronian and firuja one
one thing that i want to mention first
of all aronian was late to the game so
he definitely spent a lot of time
preparing for this match but it was
alireza who surprised him and i don't
think he liked that i don't think lev
like that he spent a lot of time all the
way to this move
king to e2 the big blunder that you guys
were mentioning after knight to d1 queen
to a5 this is all theory and still 15
games have been played with knight to c3
nobody played this move came to e2 but
he immediately played king to e2 my
understanding after king to e2 is that
he only calculated queen takes a4 and he
was just trying to catch up on time
because at this point he had one hour
and 16 minutes on the clock his opponent
was just blitzing every single move one
hour and 33 minutes for ali reza so i
think he was just a little bit upset
about this uh situation on the clock and
he wanted to catch up wanted to take the
tempo back on his side of the court now
on the other hand report versus the act
now they're following a game of the
action alejandro was mentioning that the
game between bayak and gupta gupta was
with the white pieces and we know that
gupta is a very very good territician so
interesting uh fact is that uh rapport
probably is not aware of that game
because he's been spending a lot of time
he's been trying to find new ideas now
the big uh question at this point this
was the tubby of this game after knight
to d7 this is a big moment because
in that game between gupta and dark
that played uh gupta played the move g3
and
immediately dak responded with a move a5
a5 b5 and c5 the problem is if he would
have repeated this he would have been
worse as black because after c5 bishop
to g2 not the move that was played in
the game d takes c5 but rather bishop to
g2 would give white quite a significant
advantage now it's a big question
whether that would have repeated what he
played back in those days back in 2018
if he remembered that game four years
ago he was surprised obviously from the
opening and he would have repeated now
also in the game between napoleon she
and dominguez i have to say i was uh
walking through the playing hall and
nepo is just all over the place he he's
boosting he has a lot of confidence
and i think that's very significant
because he prepared a lot uh the petrov
with the black pieces for the world
championship match probably with the
white pieces as well he has a lot of
residual understanding and opening
theory for from that match but the way
you prepare for this type of matches is
you not only go through the opening
theory but also you go through the
middle game uh theory you try to play
that middle game countless of times and
i think this is uh a significant
advantage that jan has over his opponent
in this particular game i think
dominguez has a very very difficult
defense ahead of himself what do you
guys think
well thank you for that christian we
just saw the move queen g4
by john and it's always nice uh to pick
up the tells of your opponent your
opponent gets up very confidently uh
paulo guyevsky had a way of getting up
from the board and adjusting his jacket
to say you know like um
you know
yeah
and then there's this way i will i will
misquote it horribly and i will be very
ashamed but there's this famous famous
story i think about the game between uh
tal and the
fisher maybe where
i think maybe fisher sacrificed
something in an idlorf and then misha
got up from the chair and took off his
jacket and
and after the game fisher said i was i
calculated everything apart from that
until the jacket coming up and that was
my undoing
i did not i did not expect mission to
take off the jacket yeah
so yeah there's there's a lot of that uh
going on right
the undercurrents so to speak exactly
i've seen that uh uh the tells uh
alejandro uh did ali alireza find the
variation well queen a6 is quite obvious
so he did get that
the issue for me is what is he going to
play now i have an engine and the engine
just wants to take the pawn and go into
the end game but i was taking a look at
this from a more human perspective and i
found a couple of moves that i thought
were pretty attractive because i started
playing around simply with starting with
a move knight b3 just going and hunting
uh this king down of course you cannot
take on uh b3 because of knight d2 check
and i was asking the engine okay what do
you do against knight b3 it looks very
compelling and the engine wants to go
king g3 or king g4 doesn't matter
and i said well why not check and it
just hides the king on h3 there's no
problems and i thought why not knight
cd2 you have things like yes two coming
c5 queen this looks like checkmate even
b6 queen c8 looks dangerous and the
engine just chills he wants to play
knight g3 queen takes h7 give me the
pawn
i don't think humans look at this
position and think yeah i have a great
position with my king on h3 and perhaps
there is some instinct that you should
be able to convert somehow against this
king the engine finds absolutely nothing
says that at some point you're just
going to move the bishop and your king
is going to be safe down the line
because the bishop doesn't have a lot of
moves but it does give white a very
significant plus so i think that
it is kind of a challenge in my opinion
for laressa here to not get baited into
some kind of attack with knight b3 or
even rook g8 and instead of focusing on
the pawn on a4 because when i when you
see the king on f3 yes of course you see
that upon us a pawn and queen takes a4
seems like a good move but
why not try to checkmate that thing
right it's on f3 it's pretty it's pretty
exposed but i i haven't been able to
find a direct attack that actually works
for the black pieces the engines are
very adamant about the move queen takes
a4 i understand the whole concept of
knight b3 but i do like stopping the
king from you from crossing which
performs a threat i think i think if not
for the fact that bishop f1 is a threat
uh yeah rook j8 would have been a very
very attractive move but bishop is just
bishop f1 and it's a multi-purpose move
not only do you take on c4 but also when
i go knight g3 i'm going to hide my
quran too no problems there so you would
basically just lose after the movie
bishop f1 is uh sorry that was why
knight b3 was uh stimulated yeah yeah
but again without the without the engine
as black
you do at least want to uh
say
can i just
capture this uh
this white king it doesn't look peculiar
shaq by the way did play in against mvl
the move c5
and emile took straight away using the
fact that really the only recapture i
mean actually that's actually not true
because you can take with the light
piece and play before queen a4 you don't
lose a full piece there
uh but it looks awkward so it's
understandable that shark chose to take
with the queen exactly exactly and
somehow also capturing with the queen
you kind of rescue the queen a little
bit it gives it more squares 35 25
checkers
legitimately an annoying idea here
most certainly yeah and uh it feels like
black's
opening
what did they say the soviet in the
school the black's opening
opening difficulties are behind him
something
yeah yeah exactly blacks yeah uh looks
looks very very good uh i have to play
knight b3 i think oh sorry just just for
one brief firm or additional second yeah
i think i think you have to play an mp3
specifically to have the bishop e3 move
in reply to the check otherwise it's uh
it's a bit annoying and not queen g3
and you just and actually i don't hate
this for white
rook d1 or something i you know you
could maybe even claim that
some of these end games might be a
little bit more pleasant for white but
not not by very much okay not by very
much fair enough
all right just as we get ready for break
i just want to say that uh
wesley bless his heart did capture upon
yeah
i was actually i dragged you away from
that position
not to allow you to show it because it
was uh it was heartbreaking for me that
my
my
chess understanding is so faulty about
more training is required by the end by
the end of the two and a half weeks
we'll have from grand chester where
peter will be capturing every part of it
very good
what what's going on with q boutiques
what's our special today's today's
special at the at the q boutique inspire
us is a super soft women uh women's
grade pocketed cardigan features the
grand chest tool logo on the bottom left
pocket and as a are most of the items
we're promoting during the streams it is
available at cubatic
stl.com
your one-stop shop for
chess chess apparel and other things of
note and you get to support the stream
as well how cool is that we'll see you
on the other side of
the brick
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it great journalists work
hard to find the facts and put those
facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from lau meyer sculpture park and the
city garden to the stunning cathedral
basilica one of the largest mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing st louis is on
display all year long
ooh
now that's an exhibit
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and here we are uh back with our
coverage this is obviously the shot of
the playing hall uh spectators are there
i think it's always
nice to play in front of a live audience
and you you can see you can see everyday
people coming in and watching or
watching this tournament which is very
very pleasing to
pack them to notice yeah and uh this was
round
three how do we stand after the first
two rounds now let's take a look at the
standings which still are reasonably
streamlined we've had two decisive games
so far out of 10 and the the two people
who have won a game are up up at the top
there
yanni pomniche and wesley six players
made six draws
uh oh sorry not six or two drawers each
that's twelve drawers yeah nice and uh
alireza and chocolatier are on one draw
and one loss so far we have some tragic
news i'm i'm afraid to share uh yeah
well not not uh welcome news at all uh
your leisure bachmann who uh uh i didn't
know well personally but i was
privileged to know and uh i'm sure you
have also
known that quite well yeah a few times i
fortunately i didn't get a chance to
really spend as much time with him on my
trips to moscow as i would like to at
titan
in the world of chess a centurion yeah
he did make it to 100.
fantastic but
sadly passed away today we our
condolences to uh to the family and yeah
he was he was an absolute giant of the
game he was one of the world's foremost
authorities on alcohol all things to do
with endgames composed studies
he was still he would still come to
tournaments in moscow even in his late
90s
he was a kind of a fixture
just you know sitting in in the analysis
room and talking about chess his
eyesight was
failing towards the later years he
wasn't as active analyzing with players
and so on but yeah he was a he was a
gentleman and uh
as i said privileged to have known him
yeah for me i must say that i was kind
of raised on his
five-volume end-game manuals and he had
a a book uh i think it was tactical
tactics uh a book by averbach that was
very very popular in the united states
and i feel very sad for him something
a slightly you know
lighter reference but you know the
he was such a household name uh in in
soviet union in russia that he actually
made it into a pop song at one point
because
he used to have uh he used to have a
weekly i think a weekly uh tv show
called chess school with yuri averbach
and there was a pop song when i was a
kid which made reference to that tv show
and
everybody knew what he was talking about
the the
the singer like he was he was definitely
enough of a household name to to to for
that show to be included in
pop culture
outstanding extraordinary uh and again
our condolences to his family uh you
will be
missed and i believe the only
international grandmaster
ever to become a centurion uh lillian
thought was rather close i mean
victor corchenoy was long lived but not
even in his 90s so
a loss uh alejandro
yeah i think that every chess player has
grown up on avarbach games and our back
studies and we've known of the everback
variations and he's just
you can't state his contribution to
chess enough not only from a playing
perspective but i believe he was also
heavily involved in russian chess i
believe he was the head of the president
or the chairman of something of the
soviet chess for
i mean a better part of five or six
years in the 70s yeah he definitely was
uh was very very much involved and uh
yeah
all aspects of
chess and uh was also
from all from all accounts an extremely
extremely nice person yeah not not a
good day today not a good day
um alejandro uh
before we found out that tragic news
there was actually a kind of a funny
moment you had shared with us in the
game of richie where bishop c4 provoked
e5 and the computer said to you i'm
going to teach you something sunny boy
and then you said okay what if i play
bishop
i share with the audience
what you shared with us so the way that
we analyze this position is that black
is cramped and definitely needs a pawn
break uh the most natural one is the
move e5 you just played the move rook d8
hinting that e5 is going to be coming on
the board pretty soon here and for this
reason we thought well bishop c4 makes a
lot of sense
in some ways it descent devices the move
e5 because now you have the strong
diagonal f7 is a little bit weak now
that you put the rook on d8 then i might
come to f5 and the engine and bok done
both thought i don't care about this e5
is the correct move in this position
actually helped by the fact that the
bishop is on c4 because in some
variations when you take on e5 or when
the pawn takes on d4 this knight might
land on the e5 square and that's a tempo
against the bishop that seems a little
far-fetched but the more i analyzed the
variations the more it seemed like the
knight coming to e5 was a bit of an
issue and it thought the engine did that
to prepare against the move e5 just put
the bishop on e2 the idea is that on e5
this end game is surprisingly not so fun
uh for black i mean it's not that
surprising but after castles and rook d1
black has a couple of issues here with
uh for filling up his development you
would like to play the move bishop e6
and just play rook d8 but because i
castle then you don't have ideas of
knight d3 anymore this tempo knight a4
hitting the bishop on v6 and hitting the
knight on e5 actually causes problems
for black you don't have
the ability to play bishop e6 so easily
you need to play something more
defensively but that gives up the d file
and it seems like tempo by tempo the
move e5 doesn't quite work when the
bishop's on e2 but when the bishop's on
c4 the big difference is of course that
after e5 pawn takes knight takes this
you're already hitting this bishop on c4
thank you for the tempo and it just kind
of works out for the black pieces there
would be some spooky lines like knight
f5 but the engine's thick knight f5 are
you kidding me i just told you my
knights going through e5 eventually
thank you for opening up the bishop on
ca to eventually attack the knight on
five actually gives black a clear
advantage after the move queen c7 simply
retreating a little baffling as a
grandmaster that the move bishop c4
encourages e5 e5 and it's not the other
way around but the romanian player is
fully taking advantage of that playing
the move e5 and according to my uh
slightly stronger than this engine uh
he's equalized the position
thank you for that alejandro and i did
see that in the game of levon aronian
after that thing
by ali raza is there any way that we can
take advantage of the king being on f3
and trying to checkmate ali raza finally
said no i'll take the pawn
uh he's found the the right sequence and
i think more importantly he realized
nothing stronger exists in the position
i don't think i mean kunesix is the most
natural in the position and queen takes
a4 does kind of invite itself but uh
there was that temptation that we were
talking about of trying trying to go for
some kind of a mating attack but yeah
catch this king on yeah three somehow
but he has correctly correctly estimated
that there is nothing particularly uh
great in any of those lines has taken on
a4 and levon is now thinking again which
is a bit uh
worrying for uh for all the
uh fans of the armenian grandmaster and
the american grandmaster now because i
think
the the longer you think here the more
you realize the young game of the queen
a4 is unattractive
and the more i think maybe you will he
will be tempted to perhaps try to keep
the position complicated by keeping the
queens on which as we've already
established might just be lethal
it just shouldn't be done here you have
to
you know with uh without much joy
you have to bite the bullet here and go
queen takes a four we've discussed it a
little bit on break with alejandro i
think the the important move there after
after the capture happens
you have to play 94. i think the machine
suggests
uh reintroducing the id of b2b3 because
now the b3 pawn will be protected after
92 check and also if white if black
takes on b2 twice here in this
particular position rugby one actually
is quite
uh quite potent because uh even that
goes somewhere and that takes you seeks
uh we'll have to come with it will
happen yeah like last time uh the night
came and we had to deal with this but
uh knight d2 check but knight takes c6's
and then i guess an intermediate rook c1
after the king goes so exactly black is
still better i believe after 94 the the
engine suggests we can spend the tempo
uh with instead of taking on b2 twice on
move 22
uh we can spend a tempo on rook h8 g8 uh
adding uh an idea of 92 check rook takes
g2 in some positions
black definitely still will will enjoy
the better of it but
game steel is very much ongoing here the
advantage is not as big as you maybe
would have suspected considering the
fact that the beetle bomb probably
actually gets lost
in some of these lines but yeah
a kind of a failed uh failed opening uh
experiment therefore uh lavon with this
king
e2 business and uh what do you have for
us alejandro a couple of moves here in
the fabi game we went off air and we
didn't really fully explain the pawn
sacrifice but it is a typical one for
the catalan you see the spawn on d4 has
disappeared after the moves bishop g5
takes takes and notice that the bishop's
on g5 not on f4 slight difference there
from the other lines queen takes d4 rook
d1 looks very natural queen a7 knight d2
and surprisingly this has already been
played uh three times my former student
francesco rambaldi actually had this
with the black pieces the engine says
zeros as usual but i think it's much
easier to play this position with the
white side very clear goals of putting
the knight on c4 pressuring uh the queen
side the bishop could retreat to e3 on a
good day and harass the queen and that's
why wesley decides to put the knight
directly on d5 the engines are not in
love with this move because after the
move bishop takes e7
uh if you take back with the knight
then you kind of run into both knight c4
and knight b3 the idea of controlling
the c5 square is just such an important
detail in this position is that play
really revolves around it black wants to
get in the move c5 white is preventing
it at all costs
uh sometimes you don't even want to take
on c6 because it frees up black's
position now of course in this position
you can't do that at all uh but after
the move knight b3 the enemies are
loving white's position if instead you
take bishop takes c7 queen takes c7 you
have the slight issue that after the
move e4 i think you would like to keep
this knight on the queen side but it's
not easy to do so because knight b6 i'm
going to kick it again with the move a5
and on c7 it's just totally dominated by
these two pawns they would probably have
to retreat to the f6 square but then i
go in knight c4 and again problems with
the b6 square problems with the a5
square you are up a pawn right but it's
probably the only good thing about
black's position it does seem to be
slightly
suffering slight suffering for the rest
of the game here for wesley i don't
think that he's fully equalized the
engines don't like his position he is up
a bum though so on a good day he'll be
able to return it for equality but
that's pretty much all you can hope from
from this one
yeah that normally is what the play
revolves around you
[Music]
in order to finish development you very
often have to uh try to basically entice
white to take on six in some way to just
trade away the knight on b8
and then you connect the rooks and you
finish development in your okay
but
even that as alejandro said white they
very often will be very entitled to say
no thank you i would like to just
continue pushing putting pressure on i'm
not that interested in
restoring the material balance just yet
yeah i'm wondering the specific position
96 a5 i really the dislike i think
which was strange for me because i
didn't dislike it so much really my c4
yeah knight c4 and whether i play rook
a7 or
c5 uh c5 i'm going to get in c5 i'm
going to get in c5 yeah we're going to
get in e5 yeah so i'll go e5 here just
right yeah fair enough yeah c5 queen e3
or d6 i think you're kind of lost no
well unless i get a knight c6
my dream yeah like how do i do it i
don't really
read these kd1 i mean yeah yeah yeah i
would i would kind of
if this was my my position by this point
i would think okay
i'm winning
this is the type of pressure that the
catalan
uh gambit you know it's just ongoing it
just
it just keeps playing playing playing
and and black is always a tempo or or so
away from
uh pure equality but
uh that was why i was trying to keep the
knight over on the
inside the one i was wondering about was
specifically knight f6 i think alejandro
said knight c4
and i wanted to play 97 in order to be
able to meet knight a5 with knight e5
and uh
in this case it's the tempo this one
didn't seem that disastrous to me
um
95 is of course by no means foreign
you can make any kind of a sensible move
here a4a5 is probably not horrible queen
three makes sense e3 queen of four
there's a number of things here which
makes sense but right oh if like also if
i get the 65 here as black i i do
somewhat effectively you know minimalism
not having to worry about the light
square bishop on the long diagonal is a
good thing yeah
just finding that the best move in this
position is queen f4 provoking provoking
e5
no
no no no no because i mean peter is just
finishing giving this eloquent
explanation why the pawn on e5 could be
an equalizer honestly because
midway that speech i i kind of figured
that i'm lying yeah and lying
strong
wow
and by the way you can join our
discussion anytime you like call out the
lying are you right yes
stop the lie yes sir stop the lie by
using by using the hashtag grandchester
or uh tagging the account at grand
chester and we will be happy to reply to
questions
and there is in fact something to reply
to oh here we go
apologies uh asking uh did you start
playing the gruntful because kasparov
played very much so yeah i was i was
very much
uh
every uh just playing child of the early
80s uh i mean late 70s early 80s i
picked up the game i i think when i was
uh six and a half so that's like 82-83
we grew up under you know under the the
absolutely overarching pressure
of our
watching of watching carp of kasparov
play each other for you know month on
end right and you had to choose a tribe
right and i i chose the tribe very
easily and very early i was very much
team kasparov and uh
i did try to base my repertoire in as
much as possible uh on on guys games so
yeah that was
a very easy yesterday yes there's an
answer to that question without king's
indian too
no no i i tried
i tried later in life and it just didn't
agree with me just i can't i can't play
that over personality
and uh by the way gary will be joining
us from bucharest in about a half hour
alejandro did you have um how do you say
chess heroes that uh you followed their
repertoire and you you played the same
thing they played just because uh not so
much world champion not so much
repertoire style i would think i like
learning from a lot of players i really
was of the karpov type of
you know squeeze them kramnik was a big
influence in my repertoire i've had to
put it that way but kramnik played
almost every everything so you could
really narrow it down to halifan's
treatment of kramnik's openings
if you put it that way so i did have a
lot of chess heroes i think everybody
grew up on them
analyzing their games and studying their
style
but i'm very confused about the some
completely different subject i'm very
very disturbed of what's happening in
our chat
on youtube because we had a we had a
poll who who would win in a chess boxing
contest between the four commentators
christian u2 and me and the surprising
part is i got eight percent of the votes
i'm not sure if you guys know but i'm
like a head shorter than everybody that
has mentioned
eight percent of chat is just wrong
straight up wrong i'm going to go with
christian on yeah
no but also i think he he actually did
mma at some point
he did mma for years he did jiu jitsu
i don't get out of bed right
he
all right well
i'm glad i'm not part of that chat
no you are you you got like 23 of the
votes yes thank you thank you all i
thank you very much i am
my money's on christian by the way yes
um
lanier
yes beck is back in the tank here after
queen g4 and also we had a bit of a
discussion uh
somewhat surprisingly perhaps we had a
bit of a discussion during the break uh
on the once again returning us to the
language of chess
because there is a very specific uh
name that is uh used in russian for
the type of a type of a line that uh and
the type of an idea that uh jan is
showing today which is basically if you
use more than one word i can explain it
but it's basically a line where i assume
with precise play your opponent will
make a draw
but you do get to check whether he knows
how okay so it's just called the check
the check yeah it's you you're you're
checking a check for knowledge there but
but i don't i remember an mvl versus
sergey karaoke and berlin which was like
a check there was only one
way of making a draw and sergey found
like 15 moves in a row he probably knew
i don't think he yeah yeah yeah she had
to remember yeah that was it uh but
the check yeah clearly clearly is
checking today and uh
i have a feeling lenie will actually
succeed but when you spent we were told
28 minutes on the move b7 b6 and he is
already 20 plus minutes in the tank on
after queen g4 and also i wanted to say
we briefly mentioned the fact that jan
played h3 and not h4 and uh
alejandro was actually even suggesting
to play h3h4 later
but the move queen f5 g4 i think gives a
very clear indication
why h3 was chosen over h4 in this
position because it does give white this
additional uh additional opportunity to
uh
ask the ask their opponent you know
which endgame would you like here do you
want the rokan game here do you want to
continue keeping the queens on but if
you want to continue keeping the queens
on you will probably have to trade c2
for c4 which is not something that black
wants to do necessarily because that's a
trivial yeah the policy 4 is definitely
the healthier
so to speak over the two no question
about it so i think it has to be the
rook ending and my current preference
here is to go rogue d2
i assume rook c1 rook a2 exists but i
don't know what it does
and now i want to play rook d5
rook 2 rook d1 rook b1 is okay not to
win right it's a way to try to lose yeah
rook d5 creating a very important threat
of rook a5 uh rook a1 b5 and black
suddenly may be even better so rugby one
is important and now i want to go back
to bit d2
in order to play for when you will have
to play rook b4 i want to take on c2
and play a6 here
and i want to suggest that this is very
likely going to be a three against two
even though now i look at this position
rook b4 exists right
rook b4 b5 if we take take we go rook b3
not easy for you to get a three making
making it as difficult as possible for
black to actually get a three versus two
on one side and then i want to play f3
king h2 king g3 queen king of four and
so on and ask some questions right
and uh
i have a feeling that
defend defend it carefully this is
probably still a draw but it's not a fun
one to make right and i liked everything
you did up to here
regarding the check
right i like i i like that terminology
too regarding the check and i was
wondering if maybe we shouldn't just uh
wait for you to get
king of funky one yeah to kick the rook
right so we get something like this and
then we go rooney five and then you go
rook d5 and yeah that's so very that
actually is a hang on but we don't have
rook d2 anymore right after rook b1
i'm sorry i go rugby one and we no
longer have the rook g2 option so we
have to play maybe king g5 and then f3
king f4 if f3 gets played absolutely and
but f3 probably doesn't get played i
want to start with rook before
uh-huh so go ahead and also i want to
ask you are we sure the
what the evaluation of the pawn ending
afterwards
yeah yeah you want to you you may want
to double check that probably not but
probably fine
i was going to do it on the previous
move exactly on d5 but i have a feeling
it probably loses for white rather than
wins so i'm not gonna check too so so in
russian it's called the check i want to
get oh yeah you check the line uh you
just want to hear you
check the line yeah king h7
but you're right this rook ending if
you're going to go into it you have to
play it
be prepared to play it very precisely
it's it's it's trickier than i thought
because that entire long force-ish line
that we
have been looking at that we've
pointed out not the king-ish 76 which i
don't
dislike at all i think you're probably
right i think that's the way to go even
though
yeah i think i think it probably is the
way to go activating the king is very
rarely a mistake in rook endings
but
yeah the one that i uh
showed you earlier the one that ends
with the opponent's e3 with the versus
the pawn on b5 and the rook on b3 like
something like this with f3 no no the
other one uh
let's let's stay here but uh the one i
gave earlier i thought it was just a
very easy draw you would have queen
takes g4 on the board
by linear and again he did go into a
20-minute thing
for the move b7 b6 and that was followed
by another 20-minute think and maybe
even a long time maybe longer than the
two 20-minute things uh alejandro uh
jump right in and tell us about our
co-leader wesley soh
well it seems that after the move knight
c4 the engines were not thrilled with
this move because they think black
doesn't have to take on g5 think that's
okay too but they also have the option
of putting the bishop on g5 and asking a
permanent question this might become a
pretty fun game because if you do go
bishop c5 which is not forced by any
means you're asking the question of this
bishop of how are you going to defend
and e3 is possible but after h6 or f6
you're kind of trapping this bishop and
it starts becoming dangerous there's
rook takes d5 ideas but i don't think
this is favi's idea he doesn't usually
go for things like bishop c5 e3 i think
he'll go e4 okay
sack this guy but you can't take it it's
it's a it's a couple of pawns it is a
couple of spawns it does ask where this
um
this knight is gonna go and it's not
actually so easy knight f6 i think just
gets made it takes on f6 takes on uh
f6 and e5 the engine's saying this is
just way too much attack queen is coming
to g5 bishop's coming to e4 they still
have a chance to defend with the move
bishop d4 but it's not quite enough for
black
right and instead after the move e4 uh
takes king g2 you could consider instead
of bringing this knight back to b6
taking advantage that if you take on f2
knight take c4 is going to be just fine
but the engine simply continues 95 even
encouraging you to play f6 the game
could come absolutely wild f2 is hanging
f6 is apparently the only good move in
the position which is surprising because
the main threat of white knight g4
knight f6 i mean there's a lot of hidden
resources in this position
i don't really know if this is going to
happen i hope wesley plays bishop c5
unfortunately bishop takes g5 is also
available and the engines think that is
fine for the black pieces i would love
to see the bishop c5 e4 on the board
i think it's unlikely i think you spot
the
quite easily that the movie four exists
and just realizing the option exists is
enough for you not to
not to get involved because it looks
very risky you do have
you know a bunch of pieces completely
undeveloped on the queen side which is
what is making this attack so potent
it's just that
white has just a lot more of
their forces already in play compared to
what black is doing here
well
oh we're going to have an update on our
language of chess peter what have you
done for us
yeah i've corrupted the very very simple
chess term which meant attack the king
and now it means something else all
together yeah i i apologize i will stop
i will check with the introduction
yes come on but i really like the
we've got the fancy play syndrome the
fbs i didn't know that the iqp everybody
who plays chess knows about the iqv did
you know about the loose piece drop off
no i i did by this point because some of
my co-casters
have introduced me to the concept i
think it's john nunn's books which
introduced lpdopedia
zukzwang swish and zuke and site not
are all very well known we like the z's
in chess don't we we like luft
as well another german word that i have
always uh enjoyed i make luft in such
positions
lift is a good one myself on the back
it's easy to explain moves right
grandmaster h3o why
luft
i
[Laughter]
i like bishop c5 but you know the
strange thing is when wesley
gets that lead he doesn't he he avoids
the risky moves and moves like a6 a5
far more in wesley's uh style of play
once he gets uh elite once again i think
wesley in particular i think is
extremely likely to play bishop c5
because he
you know his spidey senses will be very
much tingling there
telling him that this is you know way
too much way too much risk to be taking
even if the computer might suggest that
it's still playable either
and let's uh check and check in you like
this let's check in with uh romania and
anastasia and christian
thank you yasser first of all i just
want to say that i'm very worried and
upset about the poll that just happened
on youtube
about peter actually besting me in chess
boxing we
we will talk about that but we will get
right into something there will be no
talking games
and there were
and uh
is true peter you did win the poll
marks the queen's very rule anastasia
tell us a bit about this game mvl versus
mamedyarov i think it's just an
interesting
battle and sense that now i think black
managed to equalize more or less and
after queen e5 perhaps white could could
accept the fact that he didn't get
anything
not so much out of the opening and
perhaps just to exchange the queens but
then well decided to play something
different right i mean he um deviated so
he played bishop before queen e4 and now
actually he cannot make castling um at
this moment and
after queen f3 i think black has quite a
good option to play something quincy too
and keep the queens on the board and
i was just checking some lines and
one of the most let's say the easiest
one like if white takes on b7 the move
e5 can follow for example and here we go
now all the action starts um actually
i'm i was expecting something out of
this game but thought that it will
finish in the drop pretty soon but i
think that now that the queens are still
on the board we can see some action
later and i really like this dance
between the queens uh
not accepting the fact that uh mamadiaro
wants to exchange the queens with this
move bishop to f4 big tension uh in this
game but i don't want to talk about the
game between aronian and ali reza
because after queen two a four queen a6
queen to a4 now it seems like white is
an aronian that is he's on the verge of
losing now this is becoming a trend for
levon he blitzed that move king to e2
and i just want to point out to a couple
of recent examples of what he did in the
american cup let's start with the first
game
against ray robson that was actually the
second game of their match he won with
the white pieces and then he had to
defend with the black pieces to win the
mini match and at this point in an
innocuous english opening he played this
immediate move a5 allowing rook takes c6
after which he's pretty much almost lost
at least from a practical perspective
and he played it very quickly this is
what worries me about lev right now also
at the american cup as well which just
finished a couple of weeks ago he had
this position with the white pieces as
well against dominguez this is a
classical time control he had
an instance in the rapid as well but in
the classical at this point
he does look like white maybe uh has
some sort of an attack on the king's
side but then he played this move bishop
to b5
bluffing allowing black to go bishop to
d7 take full advantage of
white's strange play up to this point
and lost a very easy game i just feel
like aronian is trending negatively
especially in the opening phase and i'm
really worried about that for himself
what about you guys
no you're making very good points that
of late levon has had um
these
i'm not going to say senior moments
39 years old is not exactly what we
would uh call a senior but uh he he's he
he's been vulnerable
yeah and also coupled with the time
management of uh
you know both in the in the opening and
now uh the apparently almost a 40 minute
thing after queen takes a4 wow yeah you
you you have to you have to wonder if
you know this is what is going to bring
him the the leadership in this
tournament by the way what is the record
for this time control in the old days
they had 40 moves in two and a half
hours and it wasn't crazy that people
spent an entire hour on a single move i
do believe coach noye actually spent 80
minutes on one single what's your record
oh no i'm
no i was very good i had never had
anything more than say 30 minute four
nothing okay i never went that deep but
uh 40 minutes
with a 90 with a 90 move
time control that
sure strikes me as a huge percentage
yeah he just dislikes his position
severely and understandably so it's just
not not a good position and i think as
an added layer there you
i've been in his shoes
reasonably often so i can sort of
uh
reconstruct the
uh the feeling you're sitting there and
you know on the one hand you're trying
to figure out what to play here you you
suspect you will have to end up you know
taking on a4 and struggling in an end
game right uh but as an undercurrent to
all that to the calculations over and
over again looking for equality which is
perhaps isn't there
you also sit there and kind of curse at
yourself like why
like what stopped me from thinking for
more than 30 seconds about kingitsu why
did i take on f4 if i don't know exactly
what's happening there because it
makes the game much much more concrete
and so on self-configuration
you know you know it's extremely
extremely counterproductive to do this
exactly but you can't stop but you still
do it because yeah yeah because you're
just so annoyed that this is your
position by move 20 with white exactly
out of which 16 were a theory or maybe
19 right and uh yeah this very much i
think is at least part of what is going
on there because yes of course he's
still you know he's still an extremely
strong player and he's an experienced
player we should not write him off
laresa will find it still quite
difficult i believe to win this game
yeah but
definitely part of what is going on here
is yeah that that process of you know
self uh
self flagellation and self loathing
maybe exactly
as a chess coach alejandro you're
constantly telling your students you
know not to beat yourself up you're
going to make mistakes chess is a tough
game chess is a cruel game
uh how do you stop yourself from
wasting time
with this uh self-berating i think it's
just very tough because
it's it comes naturally you realize that
you've done something wrong to your
position and the worst part is coming
from a better position to an equal and
then stopping yourself from ruining it
completely and that psychological issue
is is very hard to do and i felt that
players that just play doesn't matter
what the position is they just make
moves have a higher chance of not
falling into that psychological trap
whereas players that are used to like
burning time levon is usually not one of
those but players that you love burning
time man they get into their heads and
they come up with incredible moves after
45 minutes of thought where you realize
oh they haven't actually been thinking
about the position they've been hating
on themselves for 40 minutes of the 45
minute thing and what they come up with
could be just a completely random move
which is what scares me here for lavon
right because if you don't take on a4
that king on f3 will be hunted down so
you have to take on a4 but at this
moment he must have realized that like
35 minutes ago so
what is he spending the rest of the time
on right yeah and we might have a one of
the more quirky
repetitions repetitions in world chess
and uh in in the mvl uh
uh shock game exactly
when we left it anastasia said well if
you go queen c2 queen takes b7 black
will endorse
these complications that come after e5
mvl says you're right i'm not going
going down that path i'm going to play
bishop e d one decision is a cute little
move yeah uh queen takes between
actually losing the queen to bishop c1
that's a very uh nicely uh spotted idea
by mbl right of course not missed by
shakhriar who immediately responds with
queen e4 check and i think bishop
actually is very logical here because
taking on e4 and giving the the black
bishop the uh access to the long
diagonal i think is illogical
i think black is very happy about uh um
bishop
and alternatively uh taking on f3 would
have been very very strange from
shahriar giving the wide bishop access
to the long diagonal thank you very much
for that
so i think like nobody plays king of one
here in the current position and bishop
e3 also just doesn't look right because
95 for instance forces the trade that
you're trying to avoid specifically on
the foursquare
so it feels like bishop p2 is is i mean
white is not wars after queen takes
before but i don't think white is ever
better
so i think just going bishop to here and
saying yeah this is a draw for by this
point would you like to yeah is sensible
indeed and a very unusual as you said
quirky uh repetition i like that this
yeah and in the meantime i think uh
richie may have uh
done something at least to my eyes he
might be in a lot of trouble now after
e5 takes d4 i just hate this position
for white well rachel richie played a
reachy move that's what he does right i
mean it doesn't matter if it's good if
it's bad it's risky and it's fun and he
goes for it and that's why i like him as
a chess player
is this move good they ain't just saying
no but that's gonna be fun you guys can
try to find some variations in this well
we like capturing on d4 and it forces
white's hand because you cannot capture
back on d4 here if you go ed4 ed4 the
engine just says knight e5
boom splat splat and that makes sense
once you put it on the board right yeah
made into uh oops
why did why did
doc put his bishop
peter let me explain
i got this i got this look at that check
me
knight e5 is a very visual move which
means you're going to play bishop
absolutely
f7
and i assume you want to hang around no
really yes you want to hang around to
tickle
this bishop and keep this queen honest
yeah for the moment pawn takes d4 is
just not playable so
you have to find something else
so we have to go knight c4 i guess yeah
yes and i'm assuming we're taking takes
takes queen e7 and i'm supposing we need
what why why aren't we losing here
uh
yeah like i mean i have the same
question actually
i can choose a different bishop g8 i
suppose
is correct no
not only is it correct it's better for
white
no
bishop g a and that's why
that's why you shouldn't trade on
e4 on e4 because it gives white access
to the g8 square so we just drop back
back but that allows knight g5 it does
allow knight g5 and the game continues
flares anew after knight e5
uh knight e5 we want to stop well
actually we don't yeah we do have to
stop knight e6 jeff yeah i stopped
checking with the engine i i only know
that the move knight d5 is the one
that's correct not knight e5
knight david 5. wow and perhaps an easy
move to miss from afar right because
knight h7 looks like it's made then you
remember the f7 bishop is no longer
defended
oops there's no electricity
between these guys anymore but knight d
you know you would think knight e5 yeah
i still don't know i guess bishop e6
maybe here and and then we take on c8
then we go 96 check it's very confusing
yeah 95 also good
for black yes yeah
wow so rich he might find himself in a
little trouble uh
is it crazy to castle
yes
next no because knight e5 95 protects
everything yeah no i just thought oh
castling that way yeah
yeah but 95 is actually just protecting
everything i don't have time for 94 and
i'm not getting
i'm not getting
my pawn back
wow e5 queen b3
is on the board and
richie could be in trouble
yeah not a surprise
he is constantly pushing the boundaries
of you know what is what is possible in
the position he may have pushed them a
little bit too far here
uh honestly but yeah we'll see it's uh
it bodes well for for an exciting game
because yeah the the types of
complications we've just described are
going to be very much fun to watch it's
just that perhaps you shouldn't be
fighting for equality by move 13 in that
line with white but exactly there you go
as we suspected uh
wesley did not
play the very enterprising bishop to c5
variation
instead there was a trade terrain and
h7h6 and
not too many moves again wesley pawn up
at the moment but again this is this
catalan
pressure as we say uh for
for the pond uh what should we post up
on d6 what do you think now that the
darks where bishops are traded uh does
this make sense
i want to drop it back to g2 go rook ac
one e4 and kind of go for the similar
types of compensation that we were
describing earlier exactly also i'm
currently attacking the opponent before
with the queen d2 move because i want to
play e4 and then just take on before
next exactly do have the draw between
the mvl and the car come between mvl and
shakira who did that repetition the
players decided okay i'm not going to
give you the diagonal so i'm going to
give up the half point and that is our
first result of the day
three easy draws for mvl it's kind of
well an easy draw with white is uh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
less of an achievement less of an
achievement an easy draw with white uh
what's happening in the linear ending i
mean it went from opening to ending
like that and
is lanier getting his easy draw
well it's a draw is it easy i'm not
really sure uh he went down this line
tokun g4 rook d2 and we'll consider
pretty much all of these moves rook d2
rook c1 king g8 he actually went this
way instead of h7 g6 the engines liked
h7 g6 as a simpler way of making the
draw but they thought both are fine
uh king f1 king f71 this rook is evicted
rook d5 rook b1 king e6 rook before the
current position on the board you're
hitting this pawn on c4 so you still
have some chances because you have the
extra pawn but it's not easy to get this
king involved in the game actually the
engine wants to go check
king d2 force your king all the way down
to c1 you could put it on e2 but i'm
going to keep giving checks if you ever
go up here i'll keep giving checks and
the moment that you step up to f4 you go
rook e2 and you start hitting these
pawns
so you kind of have to hide it
um
on c1 where it's not very active and
then you just defend the pawn and you
ask why how are you going to make
progress your kings all the way on c1
you could solidify your structure here
on the king side but how do you actually
move it forward how to create a pass
pawn how to create a new trouble this
rook is extremely awkward it doesn't
have a good way of making progress and i
think if you play a5 to move b5 is
always going to be available actually
the engine says every move is okay you
could take with the rook you could think
with the phone everything is fine it's
kind of annoying that the engine just
draws it pretty much with every plan and
every move that black has doesn't see
any problems holding any versions of uh
this rokan game
wow
nice point there
when everything draws
what can we say peter yeah when
everything draws nothing true like
when everything has dawned nothing has
done exactly and
lavonne
it looks like
he's just frozen
yeah he's just
closing in on a 50-minute thing geez
that's all that long and that is not the
lavon the wrong yeah no no no no
you you do have to start to wonder if
today is just like there is something
something wrong right because uh
well as christian mentioned uh he was in
the playing hall of honor arrived late
it disturbed him that farouza was just
banging out every single move and he
kind of wanted to catch up on clark
on on the time he made this hurried move
king e2
i don't think he really
fully understood the consequence that
his king on f3 is going to be misplaced
and now suddenly he's like in a terrible
position all of that i could still
explain but yeah this position where
honestly
uh
the moment you start looking at
positions with the queens only i think
you you know somebody like levon will
know
that's not great and and the fact that
he's
uh been convincing himself to play queen
takes a4 for 50 minutes here it it
really to me is indica is an indication
that today
is just not his day something is kind of
misfiring
well also just to mention to those of
you who may
be late in joining us
again shame on you if you wanted to play
queen c3 and play the position after
rook g8 and think about it i understand
you but your your world's going to be
shaken
when you get the bad news that the chess
engine thinks it's minus five it's minus
five i mean you know like
uh that was a real shock for me peter
sorry i mean
minus five and minus five i wouldn't
wouldn't have guessed no but i would
very can very uh
easily say that yeah you should not be
playing this it's not going to be good
yeah -5 did strike me as a
very very
uh unusual uh really large number yeah
assessment for a position which is still
after all a position with equal material
yeah and let's go to bucharest as uh
christian is
with shaq
thank you uh yasser uh shaq first of all
yesterday when you came to the studio
you were completely befuddled by the
engine evaluation and that you weren't
winning did you get a chance last night
to look over the game and what are your
thoughts uh after last night
okay i mean the i think is against looks
winning and i think somewhere is uh
a very big avenger i mean it's okay it
looks
strange and the
king and center but i think is my
which i showed his 95 is his opening his
move eight is
his winning position for white i mean
i
i checked game of is engine is okay
absolutely
okay not very
good i mean just the
engines the thing is safe it's not a
certain normal uh he played but
again it's absolutely strange and
i think
[Music]
i mean
okay when you check after the game in
your game you understand you are not
very good player yeah yeah he's not very
strong player because the engine
immediately played
100 times better than
we all i mean is because engine really
is very strong now in our days is no any
mistakes but again i believe it is not
correct to play like this
and just to make you feel uh better also
when fabiano came to the studio
yesterday he asked me about this game
and he said shaq was completely winning
right and i said no no it was more or
less equal the whole game and he was
completely shocked as well but let's get
into today's game it was quite an
uneventful draw how did you prepare for
this game and what was your approach
we played with maxim about five six
games in this operation but first time i
play this knight f6 against him i check
his game against sergey karjakin
and
they played
this
sergey played queen e5 and
c3 bishop f5 but here is maxim played
queen f4
of course i perfect this preparing for
this line
but he played queen h4 which okay of
course i announced this one also but a
little bit forget because it was not in
top two three
moves in for engine but after queen h4
okay i just tried to press solid removes
knight d7 e6 i mean absolutely normal
moves 92 okay this move surprised you at
all 92 okay a little bit here because uh
uh uh
you know it's
this position is not my uh position yeah
and not styles a little bit very boring
position but after 92 knight c4 of
course is i don't like if i will play
bishop b7 after queen g3 knight c4
yeah i mean i don't like this
okay
yeah
yeah i think it's better to play
something it's a bit too classy for him
of course he is also like he's
okay but
yeah i lost two temple queen e5 queen d8
and i think his maybe is bad and i just
played c5 after c5 of course
uh looks uh
normal for black and if uh take if
knight c4 is is
just queen c7 and bishop f4 is very
important now i have queen c6 move for
this reason because
i mean after after the take there is
also is very interesting line to take c5
v2 i think it's also the knight c5 and
visual why not knight c5 is good
knight c5
[Music]
i just think
bishop is tonight he's also possibly
take but queen c5 looks very solid
because he's
just to play we should be seven castle
maybe it's long castle i don't know
maybe maybe a few years ago if i played
this
game
maybe
long castle also i tried to play but
because
yeah i mean it looks also interesting
but i understand
did you seriously consider uh yeah of
course every time
every time if i have choose to longer
normal castle i
i try to think which one is better every
time is
short castle is better but i i do many
times a lot more fun yeah that's okay i
mean why not i mean it looks very
interesting and also his tournament
situations
i mean
normally you need to play long castle
not
after one lose but
castle is okay looks very good no any
problems and queen e5 and were you
surprised at this point after queen f3
queen to c2
that he repeated the moves at all or
were you already considering your
position to be i mean
of course uh you anything is one minute
about this and i think it's okay this
position must be very good because no
castle and
i can't take b2 and this is exactly what
anastasia was talking about as well
this movie five just
creates a lot of problems of course yeah
practical problems yeah but okay i need
to i can also play some moves is also
the robot queen c2 because he's no long
castle also here if change change is no
long castle and if take now bishop and
bishop d5 and this is absolutely good
position normally it's it's no problem i
think it has absolutely normal game
chuck who do you play tomorrow
uh
yeah well done yeah how are you going to
uh without revealing too much you're
going to have a white how are you going
to uh
prepare for that game of course he
played very good last year he also
played very good to last
rounds yeah i mean he lost the last
two games or one game i don't know i
remember he played very well
but this year also he so played good of
course he's not easy opening
but
of course we need to try
to play for win
somewhere we need to win yeah some games
and
if you want to play good and for this
reason we will try
and i think it will be a good
interesting game sure thank you very
much for joining us and we'll see you
tomorrow see you guys back thank you
christian and uh thank you
shaq for sharing uh we're on lavone
aronian watch as we prepare for our
break 59 minutes and counting yeah
cresting the one hour mark wow but we
have the 13 minutes but if my eyes don't
deceive me yeah that's a a shocking
for me uh
development in the game of nepo and
lanier we had the exact same reaction
like we both with yasser here as we were
listening to
give his press conference we saw uh
lanier play what we immediately assumed
was a losing move like double double
triple question mark blunder yeah we
were expecting
says pawn endings are also a draw even
if you're up on down don't don't don't
fret yeah we were expecting with the
phrasing yeah check as uh prescribed by
alejandro the king will come to d5 etc
so we were all
assuming that was going to be the case
when suddenly and shockingly
king
d5 allowing an immediate king and pawn
end game were upon up
and i have my mouth open and horror as
you're pointing out that the engine said
zero and not and not even with only
moves basically as long as you don't
commit any grievous mistakes here right
you're completely fine apparently
because the white structure is it's very
difficult for white to actually create a
passer on the king's side and the threat
yeah and the threat of a b5 break locks
down the the white king so efficiently
that white is not wars but white is also
not at all better here so
so this optical illusion of being a pawn
up because of this
b5 business
these bonds doubled on the queen side
makes all the difference in the world
and it's actually a draw remarkable
after i'm wondering if it's still a draw
i think i think it is
but black starts pressing right i think
i think it still is yeah but uh yeah
it's it's really quite shocking just how
how much of a leeway black black has in
this structure because wow because of
the fact that the g pawn uh g pawns are
double it's not really it's not
maybe even
so much about the the passer on the a
file because the machine also just goes
a6 and and chills
uh it's just that it's so difficult to
create a passer on the king side that
you have to
uh
you have to commit to to to a lot there
for white and the black king is just
more active exactly
and by the way uh lavonne
is alive
he did not go into a coma he did trade
the queen after a long long long long
thing the correct decision has finally
been been reached because yeah the the
more you think there the more i think in
particular for us for us watching
the the feeling was that he he might
just talk himself into something out of
his desire not to play the sand game but
right the correct decision has been
reached he also
yeah well uh yeah the recapture of the
queen was never going to it was not in
doubt and he did it immediately and this
is the whole point when the king was on
e2 this
capture did not work b2 b3 but now with
the king on f3 pardon me now with the
king on f3 the desired b3 simply walks
into a fork means that white is going to
lose this pawn and now
it's up to uh lavon to figure out
how to make this as difficult for his he
left himself 12 minutes against an hour
here for and still i mean they made a
number of moves here it's not 12 or
something right but he still has about
20 moves to make and he left himself as
you can see on your screens here eleven
eleven minutes and uh and a half and he
didn't play immediately after queen
taken he doesn't yeah he thought he did
another move right right no this is like
i'm legitimately thinking uh
he is just
not not particularly well today i'm i'm
all right and we will sneak in a break
and we will see you on the other side
for this
round three and on the other side of the
break we have one gary kasparov to join
us
[Music]
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station
with a new mirror maze light shows and
the 20-story high st louis wheel it's
enough to make any parent feel like a
st lou star
always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate chess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institution's
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
where's
[Music]
that's our show now go play yours at
reasonboat.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and uh
welcome back to our coverage of round
three of the super bad chess classic uh
here's the view of the playing hall we
have one game already over today
and more games still very much in
progress
and this is our standings yeah but uh uh
all the people tied for first currently
on your screen maxim has played three
games and uh
jan and wesley are still in play today
so they have a game to spare so to speak
and chakri are also having played uh
having the draw
as well uh the game of lavon has just
kind of mystified us peter it is
buffling what's uh what's happening and
uh
you you kind of want to ask him what's
going on but he also don't want to ask
him what's going on because the feeling
is really the answer we will we will not
really enjoy the answer it it really
does look like something is not quite
right uh a series of long things
for uh lavon has led him into a position
where
count him that's our three connected
past pawns for black and he's played
side he's played king jitsu and somewhat
oh no not surprisingly because i was
about to blunder a piece i wanted to
suggest a5 with the idea of meeting
bishop the a6 with bishop before check
right but then rook takes before and
bishop takes a four which is true
so exactly exactly so
uh because of bishop takes c6 as you
were pointing out that's the threat we
do have the move knight b6
i
i must say i'm a little bit surprised by
the move knight b6 and i
kind of like the knight hanging out here
the ball is hanging yeah and uh and now
rook a1 i think this is what he didn't
like now rook a1
yeah trying to provoke try trying to
provoke b5 and play 94.
aha i think i think this is what he was
he was trying to achieve like king c2
here for instance maybe i see an mb594
and try to attack those pawns i suspect
it maybe is still playable maybe 94 i
can play uh king b6 and then rook c8 or
something uh and because of that maybe
king c2 is the wrong square because this
appears to protect everything actually
just in time to protect yeah so maybe i
should choose a smarter square of
division before check i'm not sure if a
smarter square exists do you have a
smarter exactly that's why i chose situ
but maybe but maybe
well just having said that too there's
absolutely nothing wrong with knight b6
because king c7 is always on uh black's
agenda
and uh
well even now at least
this bishop on g2 which is biting
granite on this long diagonal is now
eyeballing an opportunity let's just
play f7 f6 i think like kings just for
example i'm not sure if those are the
best moves but we go king she said when
we meet bishop h5 with f6 and then we
start pushing on the king on the queen
side and the moment those moves a5
bishop before check a4 start happening
white will have to abandon
uh whatever counterplay that you are
claiming to have here on the king side
and just start defending and once you
switch to defense you kind of connect it
responds the writing is on the wall
these three connections yeah it's
it's all play on one go as lavon goes
down uh badly i would guess at this
point what do you have for his alejandro
what's caught your eye
well we were looking at the end game
between nepaliachi and uh later
dominguez here after the move b takes a5
rook a4 was played
and king c6 giving up the c4 pawn in
order to keep up one of your double
pawns but it is an important passer and
after rook takes the fork rook c5 came
on the board still these pawn end games
do not favor white you cannot take on c5
and claim a win so you go rook e4 and
this is the current position on the
board linear has six moves to make he
only has four minutes to make them
though that's the most dangerous part of
his position the computer still thinks
he's okay if you go king b5 start
pushing your pawn down the board for
counter play four minutes and counting
for lanier so he this can get sharp very
quickly there will be possibilities of
pawn races so he needs that time at some
point
and just to remind everybody uh they
blitzed out the first 18-20 moves
so
lanier really just
regardless of the position somehow he
gets into time trouble it's just a
specialty right it's his specialty but
king b5 is too
natural a move not to play
as he seeks to put his pawn to good use
a5 a4 a3 and uh cause
white to be distracted peter yeah you
could make an argument maybe even sort
of preempting it by playing king c1 here
because currently i think i'm not sure
but i think the uh idea for black would
be to meet rookie 7 with rook g5
uh and yeah uh jan chooses a different
way of stopping g5 by i think just
stopping rook g5 is the point here he
wants to have the you must have access
to the idea of rookie 7 without having
to worry
about rook g5 as a response
but
yeah it should be it should still be
fine for black with precise play but
precise play is hard to come by and in
the meantime
uh in the game between uh uh richard
rapport and uh bogdan dayak we actually
got to a position we were kind of
laughing about in the break because
uh king of eight was stronger than king
hey but i was
but i was very much advocating for kha
saying i don't quite understand why
black isn't much better after king h8
anyway right and eg4 bishop before was
exactly what i was suggesting uh black
is i've i let the engine run here but
black is fine but it'll if richie plays
correctly here and from yesterday on
yesterday's evidence he will play
correctly right
it will become an unbelievable mess
which uh you know navigating and
assessing will be very very different
and difficult the best move here is long
castles which i think is not even that
difficult to realize because you do want
to get the king away from the center you
do want to establish the spin and 95 is
by far the most natural move in this
position sure to which white responds
with knight ce4
knight c e4 and i see e4 wow i thought
the knight was going to come and attack
the bishop but knight c e knight c4 we
take on b2 with white recaptures with
the queen not the king
obviously yeah a 93 check has to be
played we take on d3 and we take on f6
and
it at first
at first the engine suggests this is
much much better for white and then
after some thought it goes queen d6 here
but queen d6 yeah attacking the
attacking the knight also the knight
cannot be dropped back to e4 because as
yasser is correctly pointing out queen
f4 queen takes f7 will be a strong
threat knight six h5
creating a somewhat telegraphed threat
of queen takes g7 made machine goes
queen f8
the bishop droves back to let's say b3
machine goes c6 c5
and says
let's go that's crazy and says like 0.1
the last time i've seen this on my
screen it says 0.1 here so
uh
i don't know who i want to kill you the
engine and alejandro just somebody
getting me out of this one that had
nothing to do with it that was all this
is terrible
i got like 20 questions everywhere and
i'm still confused and at the end of the
day
richie
material ahead but
is
not enough i guess it's unclear yeah
because the king on c1 is very unsafe
and bishop g4 is also a very very
important source of contemplating these
positions and the reason i you know
spewed this long computer line at you
was that specifically
well it had a flow yeah but also
without it i was entirely baffled by the
idea that black is just not just much
better and i just needed for my own
personal sort of education and peace of
mind right in the break i just needed to
figure out why
because it wasn't true yeah because
as when i saw queen b3 on the board when
when when richard played queen b3 on
move uh 13 my immediate reaction was i
take on d4 i don't even bother with king
f8 i put the king in the corner where it
cannot be attacked i recapture on
default with the bishop because it's
comfortable i play 95 next move against
most legal moves
and
life is wonderful yeah look look at how
harmonious my pieces are looking the
bishop is nice the queen the rook this
guy is coming out here and then hunter
told me i'm much worse here and i just i
just needed to figure out why because it
just didn't make any sense and you got
tasered as well um
look 94
fine that whole bishop b2 but could i
ask
why are we attacking
are you dropping back queen is seven
maybe there is some c65 somewhere i have
no idea i i only i only checked
94. at some point it was screaming that
night c4 is winning so i had to i had to
know oh is is this is true or not and
what a variation uh
that's hard
right so many levels right yeah
i mean you kind of stop right here
because you've already got two minor
pieces for the rook and then you go
whoa whoa whoa it just makes a couple of
very quiet defensive moves the queen d6
queen fade maneuver is so difficult to
find because
you want to grab that bishop put it on
f5 and make the guy right and then you
realize the bishop doesn't have squares
and there is a mate on jesus and there's
a mate on g7 that needs
addressing and c5 yeah you do need to
start opening up some files on the queen
side because you have to play against
the king on c1 and then bishop g4 with
the intention of taking on h5 and
creating additional counterplay that way
starts
uh starts happening because you will get
some squares like if and there we go
long castle on the board
yeah that was expected
that one richie was not gonna miss the
thing is both players are actually
significantly down on time remember that
they just got out of the opening they
haven't accumulated the amount of moves
that for example linear and nepal have
on their board that is below 20 minutes
and he is on move
what move is he on 16. yeah and i want
to say
in his earlier games from rounds one and
two deck was taking a lot of time we saw
him actually going down to seconds
six five four
completing the time control
um yeah linear left himself
less than a minute but he he doesn't
have that many moves left to make
although the position has become
incredibly sharp i've been i've been
looking at this as well
uh because i just left the pawn on g7 uh
there to be taken
yeah and my question is if i do take on
g7 i assume you play three i do and i
want to play king c1 here not even rook
czech no i just want i just want to get
the king over to b1 and then start
pushing my passers because the one a
pawn is not going to queen as long as i
have the king in the corner okay so
let's uh i just want to go king b1 here
just to make sure whoa whoa whoa yasser
sarah we're not taking the part on c3
just i'm gonna take it what is going on
i'm taking the pawn on c2
i don't i don't i don't get this lang
why are you going where are you guys
just take on c3 take on c3 oh i don't
know f5
right too ah you just take on g2 and
then go back to f2 yeah yeah
those aren't really running as fast as
or or at all really
really rather slow
actually f f6 i'll go king a4 f7
uh
yeah well that's it uh a3 is yeah rg7 is
on the board yeah i assume i assume a3
is an intention and a3 is on the board
as well there is there is the option of
playing rugby seven rugby one but i
really really hate it i don't i don't
like whichever one probably the
fantastic thing about the engines yeah
instead of the move a3 somehow rook d5
check is also a draw a move that i would
never in my entire life consider
because there's a rook d1 chat he takes
an a2 i think i think that's the trick
that when you go rook d5 king c1 a3 rook
do you want's an actual threat yeah i
was i was about to suggest rook defy in
in in some positions yeah but uh just to
show what we're talking about to the
audience in this position it's kind of a
puzzle rush moment if you will and you
you have to find the move rook check
king takes a2
and this rook simply cannot get back and
this is this is why there is a pawn on
a5 yeah this is this is the entire point
of having a second pawn on the a file so
that the rook cannot really protect
uh the you know catch the cast uh that
the passer from
double the apons uh
they're not bad no but at all a3 on the
board and uh
one also on the board and i think the
linear is down to his last 30 seconds
uh so we should probably watch yeah
rook takes c3 has to be yeah rook three
is the most obvious move yeah you can
you're one of many drawings
really a2 draws rook d5 draws rook c4
draws rook c3 draws king a4 draws
could you tell me why eight
well rook takes c3 of course but why
would a2 draw a2 can beat two rook c3
same trick but at least this time i get
to take the pawn
okay rook takes c3 uh
one of apparently numerous ways for
black to draw the game and what move
number is it he's got two left seven i
think right thirty eight already
he's going to be okay here yes yeah
because his moves are now becoming
easier and easier the decisions become
much more streamlined you go eight so
you take on c2 you take on g2 and you
hold right against most things i would
suspect we we we've spoken about the
time controls and
this one having the 90 minutes with the
second time control i'm talking about
the old days of 40 and two and a half
one of the things that absolutely
changed everything in tournament chess
was the increment yeah i mean up to that
moment you know players like walter
brown literally with 40 minutes 40 moves
to in two and a half hours would spend
two hours and 29 minutes to play 20
moves and then it would just be a mad
scramble but with the increment those
time trouble merchants as you call them
were really bailed out and it changed
yeah
how do you feel about that because i've
i've recently had the same conversation
uh on air and uh
uh
there's definitely some people who
sort of severely dislike the idea of
providing this
this bailout to players like it's your
it's your time and it's it's up to you
to manage it properly your
responsibility right and uh also you
know as as spectators we are
you know you can argue we are somewhat
deprived of
the spectacle yeah like some of the more
visceral things you can you can watch
you know somebody somebody's struggling
on
on the last 30 seconds right um
uh
i
because i was not one of those time
merchants i was
absolutely angry
that
players like alexander ivanov who would
always get himself in time trouble was
now getting an extra and i don't think
it was 30 seconds either i think they
actually gave him like a minute you know
yeah i mean it was like or even two i
don't even know how it it happened by
the way g5 yeah it was an attempt by
nepo to mix things up but well there's
nothing uh very very quickly a2 was
played he took him to roxy 2 and now
after king a1
i think the cleanest way to make a draw
is to take on g2 here gh rook h2 and
then come with the king to b3 and white
will have to start giving checks so it's
not to get mated on the back rank agreed
wholeheartedly uh rook takes uh g2
grabbing a pawn and i suspect many other
things also hold like h6 g5 probably
doesn't lose either but i just don't see
why we need to bother
just one trick that you know if you
think you're
you're going to sneak in a victory with
the move king a4
that would be bad news yeah and king a3
and you're expecting resignation due to
oops it's not resignation this guy is g
but hg
yeah it's it's it's all the same you
can't really give mate on the queen side
because white always has a check from
the third but the necessity of giving
that check from the third very much
stops you from achieving any progress on
rook takes g2 i i
i can't understand why he didn't play
rook takes g2 yeah because i think this
is just just as comfortable
as the other one here you go king before
here a five rook of two like what's your
problem very good all right so as as
time control has been made in this game
we'll go uh back over to alejandro and
alejandro when we were on break we were
wondering is
has fabi
taken too many liberties a little bit
too many trades in my opinion uh we left
off the game here more or less after
bishop takes g5 queen takes g5 and the
move h6 came on the board queen d2 oh
sorry
queen d2
and a5 and we saw this position after e4
knight b6 takes stakes on the board and
the engines were not a huge fan of
trading off these knights and it kind of
makes sense right this knight is a
powerful piece for the white side and
black is trying to untangle trying to
get to that d7 square so the engine is
thinking all right put the knight on d6
and just crunch the black position
hopefully get a pawn on e5 and anchor
that guy on the dark square or play the
move knight e5 which immediately targets
the pawn on c6 and this allows black
from getting access to the d7 square not
just because the c6 pawn is hanging but
because the knight on e5 controls d7 but
i find knight takes p6 to be kind of a
strange move i think that after queen
takes he must have completely forgotten
that the rook can actually escape the
corner via a7 and d7 because i think the
moment that you hit upon that idea this
looks very
difficult to play actually for the white
side for any kind of advantage the only
reason you're doing this particular
variation you're playing for a win right
and after e5 row k7 did come on the
board and you can see how black is
untangling you put the rook on d7 the
rook on d8 the knight will eventually
rejoin the game and meanwhile what are
you gonna attack with white this bishop
is attacking c6 good for you but what
what am i going to do in the meantime
rook c1 is just not enough he's played
the move queen f4 with d7 and he's
gotten rook d6 trying to create counter
play in this position rook fda might
come and you will have a passport on d6
eventually but will it be enough to hold
the draw because this is now what fabio
is playing for he is down upon and the
engines don't think he has enough
compensation let's go to the linear game
as we are expecting that to be a
handshake
king b5 no any moment no
that's i think wrong stylistically you
have to capture the last pawn at the
same time you don't have like this is
not not right now you have to make a
move you have to play king b5 king takes
a four and then king takes a five kick
takes f3 yes i very much disagree with
this naked kings
and uh and jan did end the game with
more time than he started with but
that's with the addition of the 30
minutes so it doesn't he's he's done
this in his career without the addition
of the 30 minutes so it's less
impressive than some of his early
efforts uh
very well played
game but it's also just felt like so
much of that was at home preparation
by both players
absolutely funny we didn't curse
ourselves so
yesterday we were analyzing the game of
shaq and
they'll never play this they'll never
play this they'll never get into this
today i just straight up said
richard will play all of these
yeah
knight ce4 as as televised yeah it is
worrisome that dak has 11 minutes in
this position that's not a lot of
minutes to figure stuff out it's just so
complicated and as you were mentioning
peter this is almost all fours and
there's so many tempting variations in
this position for dak to calculate right
do you throw in knight takes c4 do you
throw in bishop takes b2 check at what
point do i go knight d3 do i find this
move uh this crazy line of going with
the queen back to f8 that's so much to
calculate when your clock is ticking
below 11 at this point exactly
exactly yeah this is this is going to be
difficult for him in particular because
let's say knight takes e4 right here
doesn't look stupid at all but after
takes d4 you are in significant amounts
of trouble and uh you have to assess it
correctly you have to figure out what's
going on
uh and yeah 11 minutes is not much for
this position definitely
no and
like you say you're you're attracted to
the move knight e4 because you're
thinking you can bail yourself out with
queen h6 check
wrong always always
be three yeah completely wrong you'll
always run into bishop e3 that is why
this variation which was our
our original variation way back when we
started
analyzing all of these lines
and we got here and when you
produced this engine i did
yeah
variation i was just like
i would like to thank my elementary
school teacher for teaching me how to
read which is exactly
exactly exactly exactly uh this is
really still
another one of those
well what can i say richard rapport
games that are just completely
confounding it is yeah wow very much
continuous uh true to forum here with a
game that is very very difficult to
and to understand and alejandro uh how
is our
friend levon aronian doing well better
than a couple of moves ago of course
these three past pawns are still there
but he's found some sort of counter play
he's planning on after the move rook g1
somehow this knight got to h6 that's a
different story but he's planning to
play bishop e4
rook g8 and just gobble up that pawn on
h7 and say you know you know what this
h-pawn
it's a source of counter play if you
ever play f5 i'm gonna take that pawn
because it's on the light square and
it's not necessarily true the pawn is
gonna get there anyway so
it suddenly becomes a bit of a mess here
i don't think that the way alaresa has
played this so far has been very good
first of all of all allowing this knight
to get here maybe not correct and second
what is the bishop doing on c5 because
here the bishop f3 bishop c5 seem to be
okay
sorry
it keeps popping up
in this position and after f6 the angels
really didn't like f6 prefer the move
rook fade a tough move to play in my
opinion but they really don't like the
fact that you haven't started you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gotta push him at some point
and
is just regrouping his pieces the king
is already close to the queen side you
will have time to play bishop e4 and
rook g8 and that passed h pawn well at
least something to worry about for black
so i'm not gonna give uh
levon's chances up for dead but let's go
to bucharest as we have christian
carrillo with a special guest
thank you alejandro yes indeed we are
here with a very special guest amanda
needs absolutely no introduction that is
the 13 world champion gary kasparov the
patron of the grand chester gary welcome
back to the studio
yesterday we were discussing about uh
the superbad foundation tell us a bit
about the partnership of the saint louis
chess club granchester as well as the
very strong superbad foundation and the
partnership they're developing
look i think we were now enjoying a very
comfortable situation as a grandchild
of having uh
strong supporters on both sides of
atlantic uh it's saint louis uh
chess club it's the it's uh the founding
place of granchester and also the
capital of
the world chess but now i'm pleased to
say that uh bucharest will be competing
for the title at least for the
title the capital of european chairs uh
superbed um started uh uh with a
rapid um blitz event here
for pandemic then moved to to um
um
classical event and now super bet uh is
is behind events uh in zagreb and and
warso and uh that's uh basically it's uh
uh covering eastern europe so helping to
revive the great image of the game of
chess in the region and i will not be
surprised to see that one day uh
bucharest will be hosting aston lewis
both classical and rapid and blitz
events in in bucharest because they have
very ambitious plans to to turn
bucharest in in real chess capital of
europe so i think branches too now is a
very strong position and we know that
feeding recognized it by uh accepting uh
grudges to uh events as
uh qualification events one of the
qualification events for the next world
championship cycle and i believe there
will be more requests now because when
you have such a strong and solid
foundation others are looking at you
with with respect and
view
but they won't be part of the success
success story is always
very attractive and uh and people won't
be part of it i love it and you were
mentioning that bucharest is becoming or
trying to become the capital of chess in
europe on this side of the pond uh a lot
of things have changed in romanian chess
one big change came in the federation
leadership last year a new leadership
has been appointed and you supported
that as well how did that impact from
your vision no it's um these things are
connected so the old leadership was you
know inept and passive and uh had very
little knowledge of any about commercial
sponsorship and how to turn chess into
the magnificent event it you know
deserves to be and
and uh with superbed uh investing so
heavily in in uh turning bucharest uh
into a
grand
chess capital uh of europe um
i believe it was a matter of time before
uh uh federation could also be uh
led by people that that share this this
vision and understand how to work
towards this uh this dream and we saw
the results that the opening of the
ceremony opened ceremony of uh rochester
2022 took place in the so-called chelsea
palace and
and uh it was one of the most
magnificent events i ever seen in in my
life and as i said uh um
uh i don't know what in my short remarks
uh in the opening so that you know chess
is just has been returned to the place
it deserves to be and
um
and it's important that momentum
federation is now is
it's a very important part it's
instrumental in uh
working all the connections because you
have sponsors but you also need you know
the authorities and you need chest
authority uh behind this efforts and
unlike uh before when romanian
federation uh stayed aloof to to the
biggest event that ever took place in
romania now it's a part of this effort
to
transfer romanian chess and to have
influence for to for chess development
uh in eastern europe and and in europe
as a whole the progress is definitely
very encouraging let's talk some chess
gary uh which game do you want to start
with maybe this one the aaronian versus
furuja because
well they actually played something very
familiar to you yes yes yes i just you
know i i
when i looked at the position i i saw
this is the the
familiar framework but i just couldn't
understand what's happened with white
pawns
so that's why i just wanted to find out
so what's happened how livon could have
lost his entire you know flank right
yeah and yeah we saw that yes in this
position ferrugi play g5 that's the move
that was introduced by um alexander
morozovic uh it's against me it's in um
a chorus tournament in beacon's a in
2000 and i remember that's when i just
saw them wow
and spending a bit of time so i decided
that instead of just playing bishop five
and this is uh we deform in some of the
moves that look most natural here so i
played 93 and then uh which became the
main
main move and and and and this position
again
you know just it's he he also played his
first game in this line and and it's a
very i mean it's very interesting
position because it's so unbalanced
uh typically you know you have some sort
of the oppositional you know um
uh um
uh uh
patterns that you can follow so there
you have pawns here and there are
classes structures this is totally
broken this is the the you have to start
comparing things that just
make sense incompatible yeah so and uh
you decide so what do you do so this is
the for instance you know if black
exchanges pawns which have forced more
zeros to do then you know uh white maybe
should uh refrain from castling because
you know then this time
yeah yeah but also lucas here is a so
this is that's that's not good no no he
played he played g4 first so he played
g4 he played for first and i think i
played
i put it back forward
yes and it's you know it's i don't have
to castle now
because my room is already active here
and then then there were many you know
just then of course the improvements and
i and i think it's this in this position
so there were there were many moves made
because i looked at this position also
for four for black i think it's it's i
think they play a5 a5 is one move knight
to c5 c5 a5 so there are many many moves
it's it's complicated so because it's
the yeah black has it's it's it's
it's own you know can't come to play
because these pawns are weak but but
for these pawns to be lost in in in just
a few moves uh
playing v8 which is i think fairly
i mean not i don't i'm not following the
theory now
i think it's the second most played move
or like the third
new trend and then they
they played
quickly
very quickly yes so actually this is
when aronian started thinking for a few
moves g takes f4 quickly played knight
to c4 by furuja still blitzing out
because we're still in some sort of uh
theory rook 2d1 defending against knight
d3 and now after queen to a5 a very
not typical moment for lev came because
he immediately played this move after
thinking for 14 minutes after this point
and for ruja just blitzing out every
single move he played this move king
almost losing
on the spot how would you explain
because obviously there's no i mean no
idea i mean it's okay i mean the instant
reaction what's happening of course
because now king is forced to go on a
free yeah and then after queen takes a
four and
uh queen takes a4 and knight knight xa4
uh so yes yeah he doesn't have b3
because of 92 check so that's that's
that's uh that's that that's why you you
need you need
uh to push
king on f3 on the three yeah i mean it's
the natural move here will be you know
just it's uh yeah would be of course
knight c3 i say three yeah it's a three
and then i don't know just it's not i
don't know if knight takes b2 then i
just you know you know i think b2 i
simply you know castle exactly yeah and
that's that's the quite a good position
okay
very complicated very very complicated
but you know i would i would probably
say why this is doing fine so um
yeah
and interesting enough
yeah i mean yeah what is the um
zero five a little bit better for why it
goes queen b6 so let's try and get to go
to the land game but but i'm sure still
knew some sort of idea
but you know whatever happens is this
definitely you know white would keep one
pawn alive yeah so that's that's for
sure because what's happening in the
game you know this is this but i just
want to ask you one more question about
this moment because after queen takes a
four after queen takes a four for black
at this point left spent one
hour english is high perugia after king
e2 you know yeah
spent 20 minutes yes i think he's just
he probably couldn't do this
why not i think this is why nobody plays
it in the king i think in blitz he would
have played queen e6 instantly because i
don't see many other options but i think
he was checking maybe because they don't
play so quite quickly
maybe maybe maybe he's missing something
i think it is he kept calculating
calculating but decided to do this
it's it's good you know i just thought
you go queen e6 i'm gonna take all the
pawns all the white pawns on on
what goes through your mind right now
you see this position queen a16 f3 queen
takes a4 was played on the board and now
you spend one hour what are you thinking
about in that one hour
are you just disgusted with your
position with your decision making up
for this point of course
cursing i think i think levon is yeah
this is definitely personality it's just
uh he
he just
because if you don't take on a4 you're
going to get you couldn't believe yeah
but but but here is as you know this is
he played king e2 so was there any
chance you know just to go knight d4
perhaps a better try because if this is
if he takes on b2 here then we can take
on b2 take b2 and play with b1 yes and
that's okay and we take paul yeah
because
he's not c2 yes
so uh yeah but it's the knight d4
so what because now we won't play b3
because let this knight not protect the
pawn i mean maybe this after bishop just
saying sticking with
this was definitely the best try for uh
yeah and this is yeah maybe room g8 i
don't know it seems to be
okay
perhaps uh slightly different like
bishop h3 yeah still not the second i i
i don't lose the pawn you don't have to
face three uh no but this is the still
okay
it's been one hour i think again it was
more most about cursing yeah you can
check with lego when it comes back yes
but uh
and now we got all the way to oh wait
wait wait wait and i just actually
yes
and now it seems like after knights it
may be nice not c4
yeah
actually
there also was uh
but perhaps with the bishop on g2 then i
can go king to e2 yeah
yeah
this is a completely different story
right and yeah but still you have to go
still kingdom still king or two and
still the other night situation still
still still some of the threats so yeah
maybe there's again there's some some
sort of
encounter play because in the game
yeah he just you know they played and so
this is the
what do they know
right now they're at this point and
we're actually are we discussing the
stations as well so what i would i would
start with a five now because you know
just it's a five and then knight h6 and
then i just do whatever try to push the
parts yeah i start to push the pawns so
i just think maybe i go pieces
i don't know
knight c4 check
maybe d5 yeah
okay three points three points three and
you only have two on this side and two
they're not moving yeah no no they're
not moving they're not moving three and
this is just so silly it seems that it's
just you know it's it's better and he
did play the move f5
he just f5 is on the board six minutes
for lev how would you rate your survival
his survival chances live once
29.97
not
look high had very good position
yesterday and he blew it up
but i don't think he'll it's
if he doesn't win this position
something is wrong so something is wrong
he definitely has to reconsider his uh
his preparation style uh because you
know he you know he was out
of um
for six months for five months
yeah but um even if he's rusty now i'm
sure he'll deliver absolutely let's uh
jump into this game the one between the
all-american clash between faviano and
wesley what do we have here we have
unless my eyes betray me we have an
extra point for black yes which is
amazing so there was a quiet catalon
opening and now it's just black as an
extra pool
so um
and what are the plans here for each
side for looking at white look the plan
is just knight goes on d7 that goes to
f6 and eventually we try to win this
pawn knight v8 route ideal yes ideally
yeah
so what white can do so this is to bring
bishop on d5 it's probably not important
because
the knight c6 knight before so you have
to guard the c6 square square you know
we have to find a useful move right now
b3 but still you know just i go knight
d7
so if you go bishop to the knight of 695
so that's the i don't know how to how
you
i don't know
g2 but this is
so what if i just go king rook to d7
okay so now basically the computer is
trying to gain some sort of
play on this side with g4 which is very
unrealistic
and g5
doesn't seem like much i'll be very
surprised if there's anything there so
let's see let's see how and wesley
is there supposed to there was a catalan
you know that's the
yeah i played it a few times uh this
line you know and uh and the
i remember that's the
uh
first time i faced it against courtney
uh in in candidates was black
and i think i played some horrible move
like people here
but uh but then corporal actually this
is
when i when we played his surprise we
should be serving the idea just to move
back and uh and then i also played one
game against kramnik so i never had pro
great results in this in this line but
now this is their new move c6 huh this
is interesting the idea is somewhat in
the corners exactly more than modern
modern chess
and then they four before and uh yeah
the partner survived
and they just
gave paul's opponent
it looks like a good compensation for
white but but somehow he managed to
lose all the
wesley might be on his way to get his
second victory there's something about
him whenever he plays in the grand chess
tour did you have a favorite tournament
back in the day
yes what was your favorite turn the one
where you played just impeccable truss
for me it was more about periods
experiences not about tournaments so
this is i um i played vegans my family
my results were getting worse and worse
plus seven plus six plus five
right
well instead of losing ground right
right uh
i'm easily winning it yeah well not yeah
but winning tournaments and uh and i
played many little hours tournaments
that was not that's like a tradition so
not of them some of them were good some
of them are so good yeah so it's there
but uh
uh
i would say yeah i like because so it's
uh
um
but how many conditions were clients
that's uh definitely leonardo's
i think one to four tailbooks but it's
81 89 91 quite several 97
different organizations yeah so
traditional probably luminaris and and
yeah and we had a series of of uh world
cup 8889 but it was just one one season
well
you wanted three in a row wesley won it
last year and now two and a half out of
three if he wins that's a good start
and then this last game that we have the
crazy battle yeah because we reported
completely insane yeah this is this is
this 92 i mean it's
the output c6 here how much did he spend
he actually played this game all the way
until
this move yeah actually bishop to b2 was
also played knight to b7 he played it
against gupta in 2018.
okay so he has some sort of experience
at this point gupta played them with g3
but but but you know just it's look he's
still scared and he's still experienced
or not he spent nearly 20 minutes
younger and the report spent only 10 and
uh and then
but it's interesting you know this is e5
and then quickly here is here is here
here is it
it's probably it's important moment
uh
yeah so king of fate
which was leading to some wild
complications knight week four queen is
seven ninety five five and let's say yes
this is the uh
95 yes yes and now after bishop to six
you have to play
and then make a quiet move knight d5
again it was so powerful we look at this
right but it's yeah it's but now while
the right position is collapsing yeah
yes they just have to uh take on a3 and
just sacrifice and then give bishop
piece back because this is this is lost
already but this is wild stuff yeah this
is absolutely wise it's impossible to
calculate these type of things yeah from
afar by the way
and i just don't get this yes basically
if you play neither five here
so this is yeah and this is amazing
bishop b6 knight takes his servant he
takes f2 that's the yeah it's amazing
yes this is king you don't have worked
for the king wow
somehow
so that's really interesting so uh but
king hate and it's it's amazing you know
it seems that black was fine but but
just you know after castle it's the
things we're just getting absolutely
wrong for for black so just
yeah somehow report always creates this
place exactly i want to ask you about it
yes
what is it about report yesterday we saw
he played incredible defensive chess
against mommy the error my earlier both
himself and caruana thought white is
completely win crushing
with the king only seven for black
rich rapport didn't have any problems he
found all the best moves all the engine
moves and equalized quite handily
what is that by the way is we talked
about he took on the h3 eventually yes
he did yes
he did he found everything
look i think it's a fresh approach you
know i think he's just you know he he
enjoys playing chess and that's the i
i love watching games
like the game
you mentioned yesterday game with yara
for this game because it shows that uh
the even classical chess has has has its
room uh in the modern world so this it's
more about attitude of the player rather
than about you know a game being
depleted exhausted no it's this is you
want to play you don't you always have
room to to to to make things exactly
exactly and it's this report keeps you
know uh proving it you know time and
again almost every single game and that
is not c4 move 17 and black is in really
really big trouble now so i think here
is what probably only chance was just
two two two yeah with queen d6 yes
winter d6 was yeah i guess he played
this
knight knight fh5 which is the best move
yeah but now keys now he had probably
gone faith yes
again looking at passive approach
yeah but it's still because at the end
of the day you know this only chances is
to to create okay some come to play we
should go somewhere i guess
somewhere and then i'll be shook g4 try
to focus on the knight yeah or c5 yeah
or c5 c5 maybe but it's a game but look
it's rook for two nights but
queens are bored and
well it would be an interesting fight
absolutely but he just said this is it's
so easy to make a movie and just check
but czech is is is seems to be a wrong
wrong move because now the queen is is
is is so yes
25 and all queen g5 may be coming on the
board
maybe not actually i don't think this is
a5 i don't want to yeah and he just you
know we just
but you know what this is i think it's
just you know this is this here maybe h3
here h3 okay
yeah but this is take and take because i
thought about a b4 maybe you can play g4
here yes
yes yes that's right this is yes this is
just and then g5 and you don't you don't
get there in time yeah because my queen
the defense
this is actually quite a funny yeah yes
yes
yes yes
take rook takes and king b2 is yes yes
king b2 is you cannot play
but
yeah a lot of fun yeah so um
yeah but um
to
push the bishop yeah but still still can
define it with this wild stuff and right
now
three minutes for uh
deck and 17 minutes for
richie this one seems to be going a
reaches way
yeah
i'll be surprised or not so so bishop
should go somewhere else yeah b3 it
should be three now finally the queen is
somehow yeah
escapes
g6 doesn't work yes
maybe one of the bishops
seems like everything
gives white a decisive advantage in this
position
gary thank you very much for joining us
no that that's it we actually had two uh
draws
two draws the one between mvl and this
one as you were mentioning
black is doing what you uh wanted yeah
just push the parts anyway so we'll keep
watching this keep watching it thank you
very much gary for joining us thank you
we'll see you in the next few days guys
back to you thank you christian thank
you gary you can see how gary just
immerses himself and he can't stop yeah
he he likes talking about the gct
understandably because it's his uh you
know he will he created he created the
the series and he was very much
instrumental in creating it but then he
gets an opportunity to talk about chess
and this is where his eyes like yeah
exactly
he
whatever the positions are he just
starts looking around very clear that he
he still has a lot of passion for the
game and
an absolute found of understanding and
it's always very very
you know exciting to just hear him talk
about any position exactly uh speaking
of the positions uh alejandro uh jumped
to that one
uh with uh richie yeah this is a crazy
game i'm trying to analyze the position
because richard has played them with
bishop here rook dd8 and of course he
could repeat once and but that gets that
closer to time control i'm not sure that
he is in the mood of repeating here i
was wondering if he wants to play the
move rook e1 i think so defending that
bishop you cannot take twice because
well you cannot take because it's just
made right and then what do you do you
don't have any rook take say five time
moves bishop takes h5 bishop takes h5
doesn't help you but black has the
slightly to me surprising king g8 and
that renews the threat of rook takes e8
but more importantly it kind of traps
that bishop right it doesn't have a lot
of squares and i'm not finding a way
forward for white in this position so
rookie one is actually on the board and
it's up to dak to find the move king g8
the only move that keeps him with an
equal position according to the engine
and everything else is lost so let's see
if he goes ahead and finds it because
this is a crucial moment in this game
three and a half minutes three and a
half minutes yeah not going to be easy
but
findable just because of how bad of
everybody else everything else is so bad
by uh process of elimination i think you
get to king g8 very quickly how bad is
it peter
lavonne
there it is
yeah
three three connected past pawns but
is levon getting some counter play we do
have these moves on the board and um
what's your question yeah we were
discussing this uh while while listening
to gary uh specifically this position
because
uh black has the option here of playing
knight e4 trying to preserve some
material but the bigger question is
let's say i play b5 knight at five i
take on f5 i play h7 h6 right uh
now we've got these three guys if white
if white somehow manages to give up the
bishop for two of them
i mean ideally three but even maybe two
in some cases and the black king gets
distracted and then we start pushing it
might
once again become relevant that the h
pawn is the point of the quote wrong
color
if black is left only with the h pawn
and the dark square bishop and the white
king gets to h1 this is a draw right but
it feels like it probably shouldn't be
enough and also it's very very relevant
that the bishop on f5
is doing a tremendously efficient job of
containing the push
the the pawn on e3 is very uh kind of
tied to the to its spot because f2 it
will be hanging and
eventually the three will start running
but
you know my personal relationship with
the opposite colored bishop
is just such that you know i can no
excuse me again yeah
i can i can say all of these words i can
continue sort of you know
bringing up platitudes but please don't
ask me to evaluate what this is i have
no idea i think it's closer than uh
we're giving uh levana's and i think
that's quite bad and i think that's why
bishop d3984 was played almost instantly
no b5 you don't want to see this end
game knight e4 is actually a nice
counter here for alireza because uh you
are dropping your pawns on the on the
center and if those disappear that's
your source of counter play exactly
exactly so yeah you can take only four
here and play something like knight g4
uh i guess and try to get the knight uh
to to pick up the pawn on e4 but my
problem is
the three will probably run much much
faster
yeah the light squared bishop was doing
a great job i don't think the knight is
doing
uh as good as not not even close uh
any other ways of mixing it up p3 i
don't particularly like i don't quite
know why but it doesn't feel right to me
i probably just go back to d6 right well
then i go e4 hp3 maybe five which plates
are four oh
that would be nasty i was hoping that uh
that uh
this probably also works actually five
before even here yeah yeah this is an
unfortunate the move bishop e3 really
trips me up badly i move my king with an
a3 a3 and we do have a capture on e4 and
then a very cute move knight g8 stopping
b7 which means that black cannot stop
knight f6 and the pawn on e4 will fall
so now that it becomes a straight up
race uh black needs to start creating
threats on
on the queen side because the the
material will actually get equalized in
in a hot second
and and there will be
definite count to play in the center but
generally you know outside passers are
considered to be much more dangerous
than the passers in the center and black
has three
against whites too so of course black is
ahead here but
once again
i wouldn't be entirely comfortable just
proclaiming that this is easily winning
for black
very interesting that's okay the engine
is it's just winning the engine says
it's minus four and you put the king on
c7 the bishop on f8 then you just start
pushing them baby yeah i like that too i
like that a lot in fact
uh the probably giving up h7 are we are
including h6 or
yeah you can take h6
no i mean yeah you can take h7 right
right
they just run yeah yeah i i just think
that these guys are just
yeah there's a little bit too many of
them it's like space invaders right then
a little bit too many of you there's too
many uh and if you uh just to echo what
uh
um
alejandro just said
that uh putting the bishop back on f8
and
just
getting on with the business of c5 c4
and b5
seems to be easy for
farouja how is our
co-leader doing wesley took a very
interesting decision there because after
b3
both we in the studio and also gary uh
in the romanian studio we all thought
that getting the knight over to f6 and
then trying to actually pick up the pawn
on d6 for free with either 98 or rd7
followed by 98 seemed very logical
but instead uh wesley just traded i mean
obviously the knight of six gets
immediately picked up you cannot
possibly allow it to get 94. knight d4
would simply win the game yeah that
would end the game on the spot so of
course white instantly takes and goes
rogue d2 another question is how do you
make progress because you can play c5 c4
uh but i think
allowing queen takes c4 and like trading
the c5 pawn for the g6 pawn gets us to
these queen endings which
i think will be difficult to win and
that's not even touching the idea of
beat xc for giving up on a4 and creating
some kind of a race situation where the
white bastards are arguably maybe even
further progressed
towards the queening square f6 and e5
weakens up your king side quite
significantly
getting the king to the pawn on d6 is i
mean
somewhat fantastical plan i don't know
how to achieve that
uh it's
at some point this will lead to counter
play yeah and without that
how do you actually win this position
what's what's the most efficient or you
know efficient at all
if there is any efficient plan of
actually winning i i i'll i'll throw
away efficiency for just a win any win
will will suffice i think it's actually
running the king towards the pawn after
rook d2
but
i
would also double guess the move knight
c6 uh i was surprised
to me
finally let's go back to richie's game
for just a moment because
um
richard clearly missed king g8 i think i
think it's very safe to say that he did
not see king g8 when he went he went for
bush pier rookie one and he now realizes
that takes c8 is a very very strong
threat which cannot even be comfortably
buried
and oh dear you know
he just uh trapped his i mean he's
played
some phenomenal moves some very very
very difficult if not this is the first
swazi impossible moves to find this is
the first real
first real calculation mistake we've
seen him make and two extremely
difficult tactical games in a row i
think
yesterday once again apart from opening
choices very difficult to fault any of
his decision making
and today apart from i think taking one
too many risk in the opening once he was
given the opportunity to sort of correct
the ship he was playing perfectly
but yeah which piece rookie one i think
counts as a mistake and uh
um
how egregious is it uh
alejandro does he have to bail out with
something like knight g7 but it doesn't
feel
like which he can bail out why is knight
just having a bailout well you can tr
well i mean it will be very bad no yeah
no if you take on g7 here over the night
i just take on yeah i was gonna i was
gonna get in this bishop h5 nobody think
on e5 you are down the exchange after
all remember that your material down
right but i but i'm blundering well i
blundered a piece
help me out here
that's a good movie luckily for richie
fans apparently the move bishop f7
either it's enough for a draw the point
is that after king takes f7 horse move
knight f5 again force move because there
are so many threats against the queen
queen c7 check also a threat you have to
take on f5 queen takes f5 check you
absolutely have to go to j that's clear
and then this move rook e7
and the idea is that you're so tied up
on the g7 square the rook takes g7 is
the threat that you don't have time for
your own initiative very importantly
after the move rook d1 check trying to
get you baiting you into taking on d1 so
i can go queen d6 check take on e7 well
it has the move king c2 and apparently
here the best block can do
is uh rook d2 back and forth because if
you uh step back you could play for a
win with king b3 which gets crazy if you
go king c3 then the move rook f8 for
some reason works now it's absolute
insanity the position but the bishop f7
seems to be the resource that uh richard
needs to find in this position he could
start the other way around he could also
start with the move knight f5 takes
bishop f7 do it this order it just gives
black the extra option of giving going
king h8 instead of taking on f7 after
which of course the computer still
thinks it's equal i'm not really sure
why but
in this position he is far from lost he
just needs to find this idea of knight
f5 regrouping the major pieces in order
to target g7
and he's playing knight f5 first so
perhaps we will go into this now of
course bishop f5 is completely forced
everything else is just lost
and now he has to play bishop f7 which
he played instantly but well that's why
he played knight to fight
otherwise the move makes no sense but
yeah
we're back to seeing richie just finally
only moves with relative ears because
yeah and he is reaching for the bishop
but he does have a choice now but the
rook d one check no
i i'm
this is a tournament in which not only i
mean we know these are strong players
but many of them appear to be really
playing their a game because yeah this
is these are not the easy calculations
and the fact that he reached for the
bishop and then stopped himself because
clearly he realized king h.8 queen of
five queen d6 is at least very playable
mm-hmm
the on three minutes
you know he's
he's you know seeing he's seeing it
large large as a football yeah
it's amazing but for me this uh line
of
king takes f7 queen takes f5 check king
g8 rook d1
rook e7 uh
attacking e7 i completely missed i mean
i just completely missed this is yeah
rookie one is very cute and i think the
point with including rook d one rook d2
is that uh that move rook fade that
alejandra mentioned after let's say king
c3 or king b3
uh
the point is
that now after rook f8 if white goes
something like queen e5 we have an
additional rook takes g2 which wasn't
there earlier and this is i guess why
we're not playing rook fade in the
current position because queen e5 would
be quite strong
at least that's my
guess yes and
limited understanding of what's going on
here by the way
also leads to just the draw
we have rook of seven there right how
does white make a draw there you go
rookie six i mean
queenie five recap
which position yeah now rookie seven
cafe
rookie seven or a cafe yeah and white
has queen e5 rook of seven rookie six
and the queen on h6 once again uh is so
awkward that g6 knight f6 check
i'm guessing king of f8 is you're taking
that yeah you take it yeah you have to
take one of those
worried if i were black
doesn't look like a winning attempt
i know no it doesn't no it doesn't look
like a winner uh we i believe we have
rookies
on the board so rook fade is okay rook
d1 is okay
um
i find it interesting that
diock in time trouble he gets up from
the board he hovers close to the table
he's not like he's running out of the
tournament all or something like that
but he doesn't sit
sit at the board when it's not his turn
queen tess
f5 king g8 rookie seven on the board
rook d won check
this is the type of move you you find
because it's simply
you're just looking for any possibility
that doesn't for you know resigned yeah
but rook d1
is equal
yeah it's incredible apparently
everything is equal here yeah it's
incredible
sort of depressingly
maybe chess is just the story strikes
again rears its ugly head again yeah but
uh
you check the line
yeah
we'll see we'll see what he does but on
this evidence he will play something
that doesn't lose here because uh yeah
apart from
making one misstep in the opening i
think bogdan played this game very very
well and alejandro uh what's that what's
the move situation
in uh richie's game uh how much time do
they have uh well back down to two
minutes and 30 seconds still 11 moves to
make richard has just made his 30th so
plenty of chess here for both players if
they want to make it messy uh
yeah we can definitely go back to that
view because i'm curious on how long
he's going to take on this particular
decision uh it's pretty crucial rookie
one rook f8 seemed to be okay this is
not quite this game this is also a very
interesting game though yeah
uh where the game of richie uh
versus bogdan we're looking at the
clocks you needed the bird's eye view of
uh rock board versus deck rapid
deck
yeah well what yeah this is this is the
one and then
let's see if we can check the clock yeah
it's down to a minute 40 a minute 40 i
mean at 40 for dark
and
plenty of time yeah that's an infinity
war
yeah and this is move 30 so that's not
not for three moves that's for
quite a number of moves obviously with a
30 second increment he you know in
effect if he makes it to move 40 he has
currently six minutes no that's actually
correct he has six minutes on the clock
effectively but that's not exactly
exactly not exactly higher
because it's portioned it is portioned
with 30 seconds per move and you can't
really
well it'd be nice to claim it but all
right one minute under
is is there any reason to make a tricky
move like king h8 i'm trying
as black i want to play rook d5 which of
course
is a very very
human idea yeah you're right
yeah i'm trying to
seduce you into playing rook takes d7
so i can go rook d5
is also is also fine really it's also
completely fine
he is reaching for his rook as he's
going that still doesn't give us enough
info because there are two moves with
this rook here which is both fine but
yeah that that kind of
indicates that he is not planning to be
all too tricky yeah
play play rook f8 uh queen e5 will be
played very quickly there's really not
very much else that makes much sense
here other squares just four no work f7
is the issue yeah i think
it just doesn't doesn't look right i
mean of course i think queen e5 is by
far the most natural move you press it
you press against g7 you centralize the
keep your queen centralized everything's
going
according to actually somewhat
surprising that he's taking this long i
would have assumed that against somebody
in 50 seconds you would you would want
to make this move early do you think
that he saw the move of d1 that or king
h8 uh where do you think it is i think i
think he's rook devon definitely king h8
probably but it's also not really up to
him he is there he's calculating
something but mainly he is waiting for a
move
uh to uh
he he doesn't have the luxury of trying
to cover everything by this point having
missed king g8 he needs to make the best
moves he has
yeah uh and he needs to also
particularly because he's playing as
somebody who is basically playing an
increment and also for some reason yeah
getting up from the board
on 40 seconds yeah
you want to be as efficient with your uh
with your time management and with your
you know energy management degree as
possible because you you don't want to
lead yourself down rabbit holes which
you probably will not need rook f7 will
happen this is forced absolutely of
course there is
some argument for taking going queen c7
check and taking on b7 but it's a bad
argument you don't do that you don't do
that yeah in particular in comparison to
rookie six okay six just looks right
provoking g6 going knight f6 check it
clearly looks right
may i play the devil's advocate there
because you you do have an a pawn that
might yeah but king uh king g8 rook
b7 like look at f8 and suddenly your
knight becomes awkward and if the queen
actually you know leaves the jail on h6
you will not enjoy it very much with the
king on c1 completely uncovered by
anything yeah rookie six on the board
yeah g6 is more or less strictly the
only mover k5 loses to rookie a check
you six played knight f6 also appears to
be the only sensible move here
don't really see
anything in the way of alternatives that
doesn't just kind of lose the game on
the spot midnight f6 is yeah
a minute for eight moves perfect time
perfect time to get up and go first
exactly
exactly
yeah yeah so
it's not so easy for him yeah right i
mean knight f6 rook takes you take with
the rook i think for white yeah yeah
and then you still have to find things
for black
white does have
a pawn for the moment
yeah i mean this is this is why rook
given check was a much much cleaner draw
it's very hard to fault him for you know
making a move that doesn't lose but it's
probably
uh somewhat inferior but yeah the
positions after d1 did seem to be
uh more manageable because they did
appear to force white to take the draws
uh yeah takes f6 takes uh yeah i'm
thinking with the rook and uh
to be honest if i had this position in a
practical game i would not at all be
certain i've equalized with black
because the genome g the kingdom g8 is
much much weaker than the king on c1
considering where the pieces are and
you're still upon down exactly it's i
mean the extra pawn is on a5 it's a
double day pawn so you're not like if it
was on b2 you'd be lost yeah yeah you're
not you're not completely crying yeah
but
or he could just say you know what guys
rook takes a quintex h2 yeah queen h2 is
the only move after rook f646 yes you
have to go queen h2 and create some
counter play but at this particular
moment king of fate is also okay oh no
way yeah oh really and i don't think
anybody plays like that nobody plays
seconds 20 seconds yeah 26 and counting
down i mean
if you tell me that king f8 is a really
legit move the legitimate yes that uh
you're
kind of reluctant to give up the
exchange but look at the cl
king h8 are you kidding me
that is not good for some reason but i
don't know why that is so so oh
my goodness also fine
no maybe about it i can't believe that's
a good move on this evidence there's
just no maybe about it no i can't
believe that
white obviously has an immediate draw
with 98 checks stopping queen g7 and
then coming back to f6
but
it was down to a few seconds right yeah
he made it
three seconds yeah
four or three
yeah
leisurely
but no i'm sorry
no this this can't be good i mean this
knight on f6
is worth at least in exchange now i
let's say
yeah okay i played g4
just a stupid move okay
just a stupid move g4
you know what now that you've
uh deprived yourself of the knight g4
check options i want to go queen takes
h2 and start getting checks
how do you hurry
do that you're learning
man
learns training huh
okay uh queen takes h2 unfortunately
because i i don't know
i was trying i was trying i tell you
what i was trying to say
you know get you so like you're frozen
like you
uh our our uh producer just loves the
word suk swang i was trying to get you
into a zugzwang
uh with my pawn on g5 and you wouldn't
have
and you wouldn't have anything um king
h8 i
i don't want to say i despise this move
i i don't like this move alejandro but
it was
no refutation if it works it works the
computer thinks it's fine but it is more
difficult than some of the other draws
in my opinion because it's not forcing
here why can't just play anymore
h3 king c2 g4 is also fine
and make black find things to do right
because he is pretty frozen and it's not
like white is severely down on materials
he's down in exchange for a pond
but a beautiful night a beautiful night
that's right
this is i mean as as
peter pointed out
a perpet uh
in white's pocket whenever he wants so a
move like king b2 uh
h3
it sure feels like um
it's a two result game uh favoring
richie uh what's going on in lavon's
game uh well the computer finally said
no more maybes about it is minus nine it
already calculates all the way down for
the past pawns to win uh
most moves are winning here for black
you don't have to hurry up and push the
pawns us yet and let the king in a
comfortable position get your king to c4
first that's where it belongs anyway
king b6 is one of the winning moves uh
you could also move the bishop away i
assume you take on e4 in this position
and the bishop just retreats to f8 and
then you're gonna march king on uh b5 c5
c4 if necessary you could also go king
c4 depending if this knight goes away
you got to push your pawns with white
but you got to push them together and
that's just going to take forever i see
not a surprise not a surprise not a
shocker but he does need to be precise
it seems like and and also kind of
remarkably from where we started uh
levon will probably lose this game being
up material
he he now has four passers on the king
side against the three of alireza nice
it's going to be irrelevant but he will
he will be
uh
actually ahead on
on that count uh just picking up on the
game of wesley so and fabiano uh wesley
so enjoying the advantage of an extra
pawn but how on earth
is he going to
realize his material advantage and fabi
basically asked the same question fabi's
moving his rook back and forth between
d2 and d1
and
until we saw the movement
rook d2 e5 you would actually lose the
g6 pawn which is something that you
obviously want to prevent from from
exactly
and he did that by playing
after rook d7 queen d2 we were talking
about how are you going to win this
position with black
and i'm thinking it's going to require
the kings well you can play c5 c4 i mean
one thing that quinji 2 does is it
allows you a much safer way to play c4
btc for queen takes c4 creating a passer
on
the b4 square without
connecting the the pawns for white rook
c1 queen d5 for instance
and
it seems at the very least interesting
although the i mean the move wesley made
is also very interesting because he went
queen f3
not committing to any of that and
attacking the pawn on b3
and asking a very very awkward question
from uh from fabi uh how are you going
to protect
uh yes this is quincy too though quincy
two maybe it does protect it
comfortably enough everything else i
dislike immensely but quincy two seems
to be playable
and in the meantime g4 and queen takes
h2 is on the board in the uh rapport
daya game
all right let me uh go back to that one
queen g4 yeah and queen thanks h
and queen takes h2 blade with this usual
two seconds on the clock
absolutely yeah and it does it does seem
that
with the black queen finally starting uh
starting to become active and starting
right now it really doesn't seem like
there's any shelter for the white king
here to search for you do have to take a
perpetual at some point yeah it might be
time did it you know knight h5 hang on
rook takes f6 will become playable right
how do you how do you make a comfortable
draw with white here i guess you can go
97 rookie check right that's the most
comfortable drone if you really wanted
to make a draw with white i mean you can
go 95 97 i guess
sorry yeah 9597 as well yeah yeah
because rook g7 is an immediate draw
through k8 right that's the perpetual
uh the point is if you
i assume this is also a draw right i
think when i say when i start giving ch
yeah this is also a draw you take only
seven and then there's enough checks
down the g1 f2 and so on yeah there has
to be has to be enough channels that
really even close
d6
uh the proper chucks
yeah i mean this is clearly a practical
game against somebody on eight seconds
yeah but yeah there's plenty of checks
to
trust the problem
it's plenty of checks it's going to be
very difficult to uh
to play against the clock when you can
gain time with the with every check
right
okay so let's imagine that we do drop
back and queen of three i think is the
intention here this is why he chose h1
and not g1 he wants to play queen f3
attack a number of things yeah make it
awkward for white to contain
and that's why we see king c2 by ritchie
not rook d1 but king c2 yeah
two minutes for
give a check from g2 play queen f1
would be my
my default setting here to have some
quincy for check ideas too
i like you i like that and i think
uh
diac likes it too queen g2 jack
yeah i wonder if we've uh if we've
already slightly overpressed or if it's
still still very much within the margins
right zero zero yeah
not shocking yeah i'm not shocking
rook d2 seems like it's going to be too
i'm pretty sure he goes kind of fun here
because you do want to have a check
prepared for on c4 yeah against the
quiet move you want to have a check
yeah uh i don't think a quiet move is
forthcoming but against it you would
like you would like to have a
knight takes h7 chuck
it's still a draw still a draw to king
king g8
nice
but rook h2 mate is uh in the night sir
queen 12 seconds 11 11 and
a h3 he spotted he clearly spotted
knight h yeah i think he did too yeah i
mean
good chess is
like a theme for for our coverage here
these guys are are really
good at chess yeah
okay uh can richie again try 94 g5
no i was going to say king b2 i want to
keep the pawn on a3
somewhat defend it and just say go i
like me too i like him i like him too a
lot very practical that gets away from
many tracks right right yeah
i mean you still always keep your per
the perpin no it's just never in danger
right like
never so you want to make a couple of
practical moves see if black blonde or
something
40.
yeah
has uh alireza actually made up because
that's what i wanted to do and then i
realized knight takes e4 knight c3 might
be
this is minus a million minus a million
instead okay yeah 94 is king b6 the only
move winning after 94 yes okay yeah
that's what i thought because knight c3
is a large threat now yeah knight t3
yeah yeah i agree so you have to have
the king on a5 basically like you have
to be prepared to protect the ball on a
four there exactly
knight takes a4 knight takes e4 pardon
me
with the threat of knight c3
forces king b6 knight c3
yeah because now we go c5 c4 a3 and it
wins it's very easy after yeah
wow okay back to our can be too played
by yeah richard understands practical
chess really well yeah
apart from being a very clean calculator
and everything else he also really
unders i think understands how to play
against against time trouble
and it's so annoying when you play these
players they just keep finding ways to
keep the game going right yeah
they're not afraid of anything let's see
what he plays queen f1 he's playing this
one now
now right three seconds yeah he played
that with three seconds but it's on the
clock is he maybe in trouble no still
because you're zero i mean it's a queen
bee yeah there's a 25 check yeah that we
can play a three eight well a4 is maybe
i mean it's probably still fine to be
honest
yeah
a4 is still good
four is still good it makes a lot of
sense because you just get rid of so
many chucks well qc4 will
definitely reintroduce and rook g4 yeah
maybe
maybe rook d4 that would rock your world
yeah
still a draw not to mention knight h7
yeah knight h7 is on the is possible on
the board of course
you cannot take on h7 with the king
because rook h2 is going to be made but
this is a very cute let me just show
this to the audience knight takes h7
check you do not blunder with king takes
h7 oops you'll find
your oops excuse me you'll find yourself
checkmated
on a d8
h8 and it looks like we'll have an
answer on how wesley makes progress in
his game against fabi the answer is he
doesn't close this game is seem to be
headed towards a draw
the players are repeating at the moment
close to move 40 for both maybe wesley
just wants to get to move 40 and then
figure it out but he has to find a way
not to repeat in this position
let's play them with king f8 and i don't
know if you know he should have this
under control yeah because
the big danger here is actually
blundering into a threefold somehow
right
yeah that h7 king g8 played in the
meantime yeah this one
is yeah i think they reached move 40 so
we should be should be switching to the
the
game yeah knight h7
king g8 as expected
not
uh and richie is also down to 42 minutes
for 40 seconds yeah but is this move it
is more forward
it's not it's not panic stations and
yeah the decisions will become very
streamlined from here because
now the knight is hanging rook takes h7
is very much it's just sorry yeah you
have i think you have to play another
six check and then take some queen b5
check just makes a draw i assume because
there's just
a full empty board for the white king to
try and hide and there's just no hiding
richie getting nervous as his clock is
definitely ticking down into the teens
well you can see uh and the agitation
with his hands seven seconds
and ninety five five
minus five
what he does overpress occasionally yeah
he went from equal i think he forgot his
i think and this was agreed to a draw in
a three-fold repetition as bobby does
draw against wesley from a worse
position but it seems like rapport
fateful move 40 has simply blundered his
position away i don't know if he forgot
that his d2 rook is hanging with check
but queen texas wins yeah
kilometers away right i mean queen takes
f4 oh what a blow oh not a blow
yeah richard on his fourth move it's
just game there's nothing to do here i
mean knight f6 check and make a draw
draw
oh my god he must have forgotten
yeah d2 yeah d2 because you think knight
takes f7 of course knight takes f7 and
then and you can't and then queen takes
and okay i i'll still i'll still press
press you know you probably saw rocket
h2 queen g7 is okay for black but maybe
i have another move like rook d6 i don't
know right right e6 would be a dragon
and then she realized
knight f7 queen d2
you just resign yeah whoops
knight takes f7
and you can see him
yeah
realization
and he could sunk in like what on earth
he can't even continue like the game the
game cannot be continued here you just
shake you shake your opponent's hand
here yeah like everything collapses you
have to trade queensland you have to
drag queens the [ __ ] starts falling yeah
now your structure is such that like
both g4 and a5 are gone pretty much
instantly yeah you're just kind of
reserving that's totally useless you
have to trade queens kind of
heartbreaking totally what what
what unsatisfying end to this game yeah
it's stunning it was a marvelous game uh
yeah it was been following it's almost
like a continuation it was going to be a
brilliant it was going to be another
brilliant draw by richard reporting
which we had a lot of fun exactly and he
ends up blundering it on move 40.
oh my gosh i mean again in the old days
where before the increment it was the
40th move blunder was notorious
with the increments you're seeing it
less and less and
now you're seeing richard really coming
to an incredibly gross realization he
has lost the game in a single move
and
for
dac i mean wow what a way to start he'll
be joining
the leaderboard
as he wins with black against richard
rapport in a stunning turn of events
exactly who had dak for predictions not
me
look at he just knows yeah he just knows
he's just sitting there thinking you're
like what what what are they happy yeah
what on earth happened there like why is
this my position now
normally normally you know you kind of
blunder you you you've got something
yeah there's at least something
something right but like but this is
just splat this is yeah totally totally
done
dusted everything is gone oh
horrifying
these are the worst losses
uh yeah because you're not even sure
what you learned
from the loss you learned not to blunder
and move 40 but i mean how many times do
we need to learn that lesson exactly
exactly
and again uh
just catching up with
lavon and we we do have a queen trade
yeah i think he'll take and go rook d6
and pray but
but it's it's not
not much of a hope
no an opportunity yeah rugby six is what
actually i think keeps him at the board
i think yeah anything else you just
resign yeah but you go rook d6 here and
you just ask this one question there
because at least you're you don't know
you're winning g6 and yeah but rook a5
forge16h8 i think is just extremely
comfortable uh could you just explain to
me the the final position of wesley's
game why did wesley agree did he
actually blunder into a threefold or has
he decided he has no winning chances
because if he decided he has no winning
chances i
i am well the engine said zero zero at
that point so
he didn't even the engine didn't even
think that wesley was better at that
point
even yeah
i must say i'm still confused about the
move knight c6 but i'm equally confused
in the position when he played queen f3
that he didn't play
it was queen d2 he could have played c4
just play c4 here
you're still running zero risks like
exactly it's a risk the engine also
thought it was close to equal in this
position take stakes and there's the
cunning move queen e3 you would like to
cover this queen coming to b6 yeah but
you can't because e6 is also just clever
yeah this is clever
but at least it's an attempt yeah you
know at least it's an attempt which with
an extra pump an extra bar and you're
not risking anything really exactly but
uh you see an empty board there
and that's another draw for wesley so
keeps the
you know keeps the leader in hand so not
a bad result but
kind of expected him to push a little
bit more once he got the extra pawn and
gary and everybody here 97 knight f6
look like such an obvious plan
honestly
the more i think about levon's position
the less i understand just like i i
understand the engine is never wrong in
this end game but
king b6 like i think it's very possible
to spoil like king b6 we go f5 or h4 i
don't know which one is stronger let's
say h4 okay and my point is i think if
you play c5 here and allow 96 the wind
might be gone
because you cannot actually shake away
this knight away from the c4 square king
six knight c4
and king b5 if i give a check and king
d5 if i give a check and i win the a4
pawn
yeah i think i think if you play c5 this
is already a draw
uh and i suspect the way to win would be
to maybe start with bish buffet
just to take away the g6 square from the
knight i think it's actually
okay king b6 first i go h4 and then you
drop you drop the bishop back to
the fade the bishop is kind of in the
way of the king zero
zero again bishop of eight zero zero
yeah so what's winning because knight d2
knight takes b3 ia of course yeah the
list you cannot possibly allow so king
b5 or something okay that can be five is
the only move but it is winning it can
be five and we take on c3 if it happens
or
if what happens knight c3 check
uh
i
think so
no i think i moved my king don't i 25
and then just go to c a5 h5 bishop eight
i guess something else h5 c5 h6 e4 oh
you can even do that you can you think
you're in time right yeah you can you're
threatening to take the knight
knight takes a four nine takes eight
no you get needed unfortunately yeah
i'll probably get mated h7 c3 check yes
king b1 bishop iii and if you want to
avoid all of these things the computer
thinks that because it exists some
checks just put the king on a5 don't put
it on b5
and that is an easier
path it's an easier path yeah but then
c5 96 once again so king a5 h5 so h4 and
then you move the bishop
and then we move the and then
before
once
and
then
a drawing yeah this is a draw
and actually with the palm h5 i don't
know if black hasn't drawn the people
and it's like it might be
it might be pushing it a little bit but
p1 is a good move though yeah i missed
that
i'm ready to put my king on b4 h6
i know king before i want to go knight
b5 but you have a3 bishop c3
exactly yeah
okay okay yeah i i'm i'm starting to
realize just how hopeless it is because
it looks like we made so much progress
and we might yes we might be losing even
this position i know i know i know
i suddenly you think yeah i i've got the
best position i've had in 20 moves yeah
it's probably lost probably still lost
yeah terrible terrible
uh
i was supposed to we were pushing the h
pawn would it have made a difference uh
alejandro if i pushed the effort black
plays which perfect in many of these
lines anyway so i don't think it makes
up too much of it the only important
thing is the king needs to get in first
and then
you can choose your way of winning
king king and yeah
and then and then it uh
wow wow and once again uh for those of
you
joining us late shame on you you've
missed a very entertaining round but
unfortunately richard
rapport
had a draw well he was enjoying
uh most of the game and right here is
where he blundered on uh mu 40. what 40
is knight g5 the fateful decision he had
to to avoid to avoid the perpetual there
to continue pushing exactly and
you really kind of have to question it
because
i understand it takes a four wins but if
we go to move forward here yeah my
question is
sorry uh knight g5 if i go rook takes f4
i
no that might lose actually that might
actually lose queen 26 queen is seven i
guess yeah okay six king eight shade i
have a feeling even this is a draw
right no no no this one wins yeah sorry
yeah this wins yeah okay then because i
was wondering what the winning chances
are even if queen takes f4 doesn't exist
but they they do they do then exist okay
yeah but queen f4 really just changed
rocked white's world completely uh
wow roquefort doesn't lose
rook f4 doesn't lose no that's amazing
yeah how why doesn't it lose 27 rook f7
i guess yeah 26 king g7 yeah that's what
i wanted to do but then i thought
queenie seven wins but queen is seven
rook f7 i assume
i assume so yeah but we have uh
christian carrillo with wesley so over
in bucharest
thank you alejandro wesley quite a tense
game with the black pieces a big clash
always a big clash in all-american clash
against fabiano tell us a bit about this
game and how did you approach it
well
uh i was a bit nervous of course fabi's
the number one american player and he
just won the american cup so he seems to
be in very good form i think he's
working
very seriously for the candidates chess
tournament because last year he lost a
lot of breathing and it seems like he
wasn't working as much but this year is
the candidates here
and
i think he's really serious about his
chess at the moment so
very excited to see how we will do so
i mean i tried to
come as well prepared to this game as
possible but for some reason i just
hope that he wouldn't play the catalan
and you came with this very interesting
move and we had gary on the show and
yeah he was quite surprised by this move
c6 back in the day some other moves were
the main lines tell us a bit of story
about this move c6 yes i first saw this
move in 2014 when linear dominguez
played it in the kappa blanco memorial
in cuba so that was the first time i've
seen it and
it seems very weird but actually
black is just threatening to take the
pawn on before
yeah yeah so that's the whole point
because before
uh
here it's not so easy for
black to develop because the idea is
that knight bd7 always runs into bishop
a5 so that's the idea of bishop d2 as
boris brooke will tell you
so black i think
uh i think casper carpool
yeah i mean i would love to play this
movie because airport is one of my
favorite players but c6 is modern the
idea is
to prepare knight bd7 no bishop a5 and
also
to threaten to take one uh i think
i think that's the main line against
this bishop d to that landing like
linear played it many times
did you feel like this move surprised
him because he was still blitzing out a4
like a quick move and after your move
before now he started thinking yeah the
thing is uh
after a4
human players normally play knight bd7 i
think there have been a lot of
correspondence
had some gameplay with this game as well
against dominguez yeah definitely like i
was working on this line uh a couple
months ago in berlin like for white and
for black
and uh knight bd7 i think
black was uh having some
or not knight e5 yeah i think oh sorry
i think here do we we get this position
by force h3 maybe you'll see it but
maybe rc8 is what is preferable because
uh here
this has been played a few times and
this can arise by force and it seems
very symmetrical but it's actually quite
unpleasant four you feel some pressure
with black because the phone on p5 maybe
yeah definitely and i say seriously and
i would very much prefer to be white
because
of uh you weren't able to fully equalize
in your preparation yeah and uh oh and
it's not easy to play against a very
well prepared play but the fun part is i
think i thought b4 was one of what's the
main line here if well knight b7 of
course before also it's the main line so
i was very surprised
and very grateful when he started
thinking but okay he played all the best
moves i think and then at some point it
felt like you were actually taking
control of the game
yeah
i want to take you all the way down to
this point
after uh rook to d6 how did you assess
the position
from a practical perspective at this
point how did you feel your position was
better equal well i'm up on up man right
clearly fabi made some mistakes here
maybe around move 18 move 19 maybe some
queen
it's very tricky like it's not easy to i
think i prepared a5 before h6 like and
remember all these of course like it's
very tricky where whites can put this
queen like everywhere the g5 is the best
place because you can play e4 update so
i play h6 you know
as i start thinking but uh yeah here
wasn't sure fabi was still playing for a
win because he helped he sometimes
played for a win even in a worse
position
but uh when i played rook d6 understood
he's upon down and i'm slightly better
and
he's trying to find some compensation
right yeah like here
yeah i mean
he in the game he held on quite
convincingly so i'm not sure how i could
have played for a win like here i was
thinking
maybe
night before so one of the things that
we were looking at was after rook to d8
route d1
and now just knight to d7 actually maybe
even in the in the position that you
played so rook to d1 or d8 c5 and now
after uh b3 i think we were discussing
knight d7 with gary as well yeah i
actually prefer this with pawn on c6 but
yeah of course gary his idea was this so
knight to f6
for example queen to e5 yeah and now c4
yeah the guy is still gonna take and now
knight d7 back and
establish the
uh the control with knight c5 that's
very good i didn't see c4 i mean i
thought the idea but after queen e5 i
thought i had nothing better than to
repeat just repeat 97 but the c4 is very
strong yeah i mean i didn't realize this
would be
1.4 like almost plus two
but certainly that's the idea but i
think like after here
white should play
something g4 yes i think 98 just means
that yeah knight eight d7
knight i think somehow you have to wait
for the rook to first go to d7 and then
start pushing the pawns oh i actually
saw this like here it's very unclear why
but it's not sure why why this black is
just going ah king of this
are you thinking
oh yeah of course yeah just in time to
grow kingdom cell yeah yeah of course
knight d7 was made better winning tribe
i thought
even though the computer actually does
like knight c6
as the best movie in the position and
when did you feel like you're losing
let's say your advantage well here i
couldn't make progress like yeah maybe
knight c6 was not the best way to play
for when like maybe
like h5 is normally it's very good to
get this phone structure but in the game
it's always hanging so maybe h5 as
natural as it looks maybe also
yeah i think knight c6 is just not
enough to play for the win like here
i thought the
i thought i could gamble
let's see 4b takes c4 yeah i was
thinking about this move c4 for a long
time because he has to take with the b
pawn he's fighting because if you take
like this rook takes d6 and that's a
pawn up and probably yeah difficult
defense yeah i can play forever i would
be very happy to get this because he has
no weight yeah and after b takes now e5
what was your calculation going to d2
queen take c4 d7 d7 yeah if i didn't
miss anything they usually say that once
the pawn gets to d7 then yeah probably
impossible to win yeah also the point is
that
if i ever take on a4 it's a two result
game because because floppy's mentioned
here some queen x7 we're giving some
pawn races yeah so actually
my best way to win the game was if he
lost on time like he had six seconds at
some point
without something he lost some time like
in the us championship
it wasn't meant to be but i think i
think here i think everything after that
was more or less uh
fine like i think uh
i don't know i was hoping to get my king
to
e6
let's say here oh where was it king king
maybe after queen to d3 probably though
it's just very difficult to break with
e5 as some checks are coming yes like e5
queen yeah
yeah so actually
knight c6 wasn't good you're
night night very smooth maybe but
obviously we do have some uh some some
big games uh finishing up right now so
yeah yeah thank you very much for uh
joining us and good luck in the
remaining of your games thank you
christian
actually guys we're going to jump right
into a commercial break
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back uh to our coverage just as
uh richard rapport uh comes to grips
with the inevitable after his horrible
horrible blunder number 40 uh signs the
scoresheets and uh
leaves the table and bogdan dayak the
local player uh is now in the lead on
plus one together with uh yan nippon
nishi and wesley so
very very impressive game which was
somewhat marked by that by that mistake
on move 40 once again prompted by
richard's
desire not to accept that the game
cannot be can be ended in a draw
basically like he just really really
dislikes
stopping stopping the game
and uh today it cost him and in the
other gay the other game on your screen
levon is about to uh complete the
miraculous recovery absolutely coming
back from the dead indeed as
we thought the three connected past
pawns was going to win the game for
uh ferugia instead he kind of
seized
the draw from the jaws of victory and
where does that leave our standings
as he picks up the
pawns on e3 and f4 there's there's still
going to be there's still going to be
some play left here because the
perpetual has to be there but if you get
the king over to somewhere like the b6
square there will be some checks which
will lead to the
uh interposition with queen six counter
check so you still have to be a bit
careful but on a completely empty board
this is a reasonably comfortable draw of
course exactly
and again so far we have three draws
in this round three and one victory
and as you say that victory the local
player baghdan will join wesley
so and and yan uh at the top of our
leaderboard on on two out of three
uh as we're watching this game uh wrap
up uh
justifiably will continue for a bit
waiting for maybe some kind of a mistake
so some you know a mouse sleep of some
sort because really as long as you as
long as you keep your cool and don't
don't blunder into uh something very
simple that there is no hiding place for
the king on this board
unless you allow it to get to b1 but it
should be very easy not to allow it to
get to b1 exactly once it gets to c two
e that is not you check out the diagonal
yeah you just give a check from the h7
b1 diagonal that is still plenty of time
for white to correct the chorus even if
the king gets to b1 probably probably
even that is still a draw but that would
be already a tricky draw because it gets
to a1 checks might run out and and then
you have to draw by but if your queen's
on e2 and i go king b3 who makes a draw
oh
nobody
nobody makes a drone alejandro what was
the moment when uh farouja
really let it slip well guys we left it
off here this is our analysis and we had
thought that ferocious would go bishop
before knight takes c4 and here bring
the king in first
before uh pushing your pawns and he did
it the other way around something that
peter had considered before we went on
break to move c5 but this does not work
because of this move knight c3 and he
must have underestimated the chances
that white has in this pawn enemy he
must have assumed the three pawns were
just winning he must have miscalculated
something down the line because he took
a long time before going into these
variations but after bishop takes king
takes c4
absolutely only move is king b2 because
you need to prevent this guy on the
a-file from passing but the pawns don't
pass by themselves this is a well-known
construction the king is in charge of
protecting against all of them so you
will need the help of that king he must
have seen the fact that you can just
gonna play king d6 threatens to go this
way as well as going in in this way
which forces the move f5 that way so
when i go here here here and here i
promote i even promote with the check in
most lines so this does not work for
black
which forces the king to go this way and
just at this moment you play the move f3
important to prevent king e4 king d3 let
me show it for the audience for example
if you play a move like h4
then king e4 in this position you don't
take that part on f5 you go f6 yes the
pawn is running but i am faster in this
position because after king a3 c2 i
promote with check the queen endgame in
this particular version is winning you
don't have enough checks because of the
construction of the pawns i'm about to
show how different it is when the pawn
is on f4 than it is on f2
so after
king e5 f3 was a great move preventing
the king from entering the queen side
and after king takes f5 h4 was played in
this position king e5 h5 so again you
don't have a penetration square black is
trying to zoox on white into pushing one
of the pawns and after king f5 he
actually has to do so because h6 king g6
catches and wins the pawn wins the end
game easily unfortunately for furuja
after the move f4 this pawn is just
about fast enough to create the counter
play and you can't go around and take it
this actually even loses for the black
side because the pawns are marching and
remember these ones are not going
anywhere
so after the move king e4 which happened
in the game h6 king d3 h7 c3 chuck king
a3 c2 you got to promote your pawns i
make a queen you make a queen
i take your pawn we get b2 and we start
seeing the end game that we have
currently on the board yes these two
pawns are alive they were taken but it
doesn't matter the point is that you
want to get rid of them as white because
they are
they are sometimes blocking some of
these checks so we have queen h7 check
here attacking the king and it just
doesn't have a good hiding square or in
any part of the board if you go down to
d2 i go queen h2 check it's not going to
help you if you go to the c file queen
c7 is not going to help you so he starts
collecting the pawns but unfortunately
for him at this position that we have
already the king can still try to hide
wherever it wants but there will always
be a good check for white what does a
good check mean a good check means that
the opponent's queen cannot interpose
with a counter check
or
generally not in her post at all really
uh because you're going to either lose
the b2 pawn or because it's an immediate
draw somehow
but we do have a winner of today's round
as we already oh
style points i'm sorry queen takes me to
stale mate i haven't seen a stalemate in
a while and this is a funny draw alireza
cannot be amused by it
having blown a completely winning
position but levon he saves it and he
saves it artistically
congratulations over to bucharest
thank you guys yes we are indeed with
the man of the hour here in bucharest
bogdan daniel adak the young romanian
superstar after an incredible victory
with the black pieces against ritchie
rapport uh bogdan that was a wild game
yes tell us a little bit about your
feelings right now after beating such a
strong opponent okay i'm feeling good
but a bit tight tired absolutely take us
through the game okay you start with
opening
i play nimzo indiana
he play relatively unremembered line
with 92 c6 and he also played this
against gupta did you remember this yes
a beat absolutely because he was
spending some time on his moves uh at
least after this move bishop to b6 which
you actually played against gupta as
well
what did you feel his uh ideas were at
this point did he know the position or
not so much
i can spoke about bishop c57 this is the
main move but he can play g3 e5
bishop g2
bishop f5
and knight bd7 but with bishop b6 at g3
i want a5 this is the big difference at
b5 take take and 25
at g3
a5 b5 take take and my bishop ah so now
after 25 knight takes c7 and queen takes
h1 knight takes a8 yes still some sort
of a wild game it seems but you didn't
want to go into this line yes
got it
okay
he played and then he played knight to
g3 i think rook to d8 bishop to c4
e5 and it seemed like almost you're
starting to get okay full control of the
game queen b3 is the most tempting move
for white tempting absolutely
take take
here i try to calculate king f8 knight
c4
take take
queen e7 bishop g8 yes that was the key
move
g6
kestel king g7 and bishop p6
and you didn't like this yes
now let me show you a variation
and tell me if you did calculate it
after knight to e4 to go queen to e7
first
did you think of another
knight knight g5 and this was completely
crazy yeah to e5
bishop to e6 yes and now d takes e3
and take on e5 and take on e5 and now
knight d5
probably can work but in practice
impossible to play yes and we were
discussing it with gary and we said okay
we feel very courageous because we have
the engine okay but why it's impossible
to calculate it okay so you played king
to h8
and uh after this
it did seem like he was finding some
sort of pressure
did you feel it the same way did you
feel some pressure from your opponent
uh it's hard for me to play here hard
for it yeah this is what we felt as well
and queen to d6 knight to h okay i don't
like queen f8
bishop b3 and here i considered
white is very good
okay c5 but it's hard to say it's easy
for me it's very difficult to assess yes
yes
so you said you want you didn't want to
go passive with queen to f8 but rather
keep some
active play with queen to h6
f4 bishop to g4 queen to e5
okay a5 take
rook to d7 bishop to ea
did this move surprise you at all no i
see rugby then kimchi
is a very hard proof to
see do you think he missed that move yes
came to g8 yes
and after that he almost felt like he
was in shock and he found this move
bishop to f7
you saw this move i see all all this
version all of this you were playing
quite quickly
rook to e7 look to f8 by the way did you
see this move rook to d1
no no
okay i don't consider because he can
play king c2 and then look to d2
is of course of course especially at
this point you have how many seconds on
the clock
two minutes say two minutes or three
minutes something along those lines okay
so you play the move rook to f8 queen to
e5
rook to f7 and you guys were playing
quite quickly uh all these moves okay
here i see rook f6
queen f6 yes
take
change
okay
go with king check
and king city probably it's a draw but i
want to play something like king
king
did you at all
think about winning this position did
you
think about giving him maybe some
chances to make mistakes
okay with
with g6
he can't blend it with king egypt he can
he can plunder he can make some blunders
yes
and this is exactly what happened later
on you guys got to this position knight
is h7 of course you cannot take it came
to g8 and knight f6
is another best move
take take
and check
king c2 and probably
check yes
and you assess this position as equal
yes
somehow i see this
check
he can play rook c2 because i take with
check
yes he's the main point right and now he
basically has to repeat the the position
right yes king to see one coin to a3 so
you calculated all this yes and then on
the 40th move
he plays this move
knight to g5
what was your reaction when you saw this
move okay i see i take
probably he don't see but
take the rook i take it check this is
the main point yes
and this is just
it but okay a bit sad you are a bit sad
about for your opponent i i like that i
like that but not too sad
not too sad queen takes f4 and then did
you feel any
having any problems uh finalizing this
game converting the advantage at all
probably not but i need to calculate
very precis precise
here
take it's very important to
to go for this check and through d3
aha
rook to d3 which just finishes the the
game might be three check and through
one routine beautiful beautiful finish
uh bogdan congratulations you're on plus
one an amazing tournament up to this
point good luck in the remainder of your
games
thank you for the invitation absolutely
guys back to you
congratulations uh diac and here are our
standings with all
the
games completed peter yeah absolutely we
have three leaders up top uh uh
bogdan dayak joining uh jan and wesley
on plus one and in the group
with uh
down there at the bottom uh minus one
with minus one we have two out of three
players on minus one are the candidates
that's what i was about to say as well
uh goes to show how strong the event is
when the candidates are occupying the
bottom uh half of the table clearly are
clearly a very strong field and uh
and black is also doing quite well
and more happening tomorrow as round
four same time same channel yes so two
more rounds before the res day and then
four more rounds uh after the rest day
with the potential playoffs on saturday
may the 14th
we keep on sticking to the schedule of
having one decisive game per round but
the rest of the games are
not really disappointing in any way
so yeah you you can't really feel
uh you know aggrieved by the quality uh
by the quality of the fighting spirit of
the games here i've really been enjoying
uh the tournament so far alejandro uh
it's been great it really has despite
the the lack of victories wanted at one
at a time but they've been good
including the stalemate behind you i the
stalemate was a great way to finish the
day perhaps not for ali reza but for
fans this was a great day it was a
really fun one
i feel a little bit of a commentators
course because we were saying oh how
well everybody's playing how well
everybody's playing and immediately
richard blunders
and then like 10 minutes later alireza
blunders into a drawn end game but
they're showing the fighting spirit i'm
happy with what we're seeing over the
board despite the fact that if you look
at it numerically it is just one win per
day but what amazing games we've had and
we have a person that is happy that
today did not have a decisive result in
his board
christian carrillo has live on ironian
thank you alejandro yes i am indeed with
a very relieved uh levon aronian level
first of all welcome back to the studio
congratulations for that houdini-like
escape tell us a bit about uh this game
what happened in the opening let's start
there okay this line i think i analyzed
it uh in 2004 with andre asian became uh
grandmaster andreas central we came to
conclusion that
it's playable but it's a bit passive
and then
during the game i kind of remembered all
of this relative one
and then
somehow i i
for some reason i thought this king e2
that is the move
which was i think it was
yeah so i mean i don't know there must
be many games already played in this
line yes so this was the big moment
right yeah 91.8 and he was blitzing all
his moves yeah yeah up to this point did
you feel any sort of pressure because
you played king to e2 so quickly
what was your opponent i kind of forgot
i kind of forgot what i was analyzing
honestly and you just thought that king
e2 has to be the move i thought this
king e2 somehow and then after queen a6
well my intention was to play king of
three
queen a4 i thought shouldn't work
because of queen c3 rook g8 queen f6
you know everything is hanging but then
just 96 and
bye bye because
queen f795 check what was your reaction
when when you saw this well you spent an
hour yeah i spent an hour yes i spent an
hour contemplating why am i so stupid
then we had actually gary on the show
and i was telling him that probably you
just feel disgusted with the position
but he was saying that you're just
cursing in in your head which one was or
combination cursing
and you finally decided to take
12 minutes on the clock how did you
assess your chances in this end game
with only 12 minutes on the clock and
probably i'm going to lose and go back
and
think about my behavior
for the rest of the evening
yeah of course
that's really crazy but then uh yeah i
thought i started
at least
trying to play my
some you know some
logical move
absolutely and try to find some chances
um at which point did you feel like
you're
at least finding some practical escapes
yeah i knew that this should be lost i
knew that even you know
he can
he doesn't have to play knight before he
can just push the pawns because i think
uh
the opposite core bishop and the game is
probably lost yeah
but then even this position i mean the
computer was saying minus it
right but 94 is such an easy loss for me
that it was just a practical choice and
94 uh i mean that's the king you know ah
964 yes yeah
you know bishop fate
and then just push the pause yeah i mean
i have to play knight h7 because
you don't get the second passer yeah so
you took on h7 that was the practical uh
very good choice b4
b3 and then you guys got to this point i
take c4 for
this move
right now
did you see the wind during the game
you did not see it actually i'm
extremely surprised that this uh
king b6 king a5 is winning study like
this is pretty deep steady like yes
absolutely i mean it's i don't think
it's uh
it's kind of a thing for a practical
game did you feel like he's energy
changing did you feel like uh he thought
he was winning and then finally you're
starting to get practical chances and
he's feeling the pressure i think he
thought that the queenland game is still
winning all the way to the queen and
game yeah and you guys got now because
uh it's almost winning almost because
here i mean quincy three i'm only
surviving because queen of seven king a3
which if you don't notice that's it i
mean white is completely gone k2 a3 yes
beautiful beautiful and now if you go
here yeah and then there's there's no
mate after b1
yeah
lev
you must feel relieved
very much how would you assess your
start of this sort of
i think
yesterday i have i had a bit of a chance
and today i think yeah something very
very wrong happens with my brain so
i have to work on it well keep the
energy up and we'll see you in the
remainder of the games thank you guys
thank you christian and our
congratulations to lavon for
really recovering from the debt you feel
like that was a win
yeah you do feel like you gained the
whole point somehow even though it's
only half a point but yeah he he was
brutally honest about what happened
today he knows he knows that that was
not great right i wanted to ask him
about the cursing do you curse yourself
in armenian or english i think it's a
combination of him yeah
we know he can he can do good things in
in that particular you know area of
human endeavor that was a cute point
could you point that out again that king
a3 move that he just showed because uh
ali raza he's saying that ali
raza thought he was winning all the way
to the queen didn't even consider quincy
three we looked at quincy two which is
not a good move with quincy three is
legitimate at empty i i don't know it
looks like many things she here should
be a draw right even continuing to give
a check probably is a draw but this is a
draw
he said that he he was ready to play
king eight yeah i guess he was very
worried about allowing the king to get
to a2 yeah king a3 is a very clean
shooting a3 is definitely cleaner but it
is not strictly necessary
and
let's just uh review our predictions
before the start of the game i feel i
was lucky
today i feel that fabi uh got away with
one uh i feel my boy pushed uh for the
win and
things turned around yeah you were you
were in there with a with a very good
shot at one point it's interesting that
uh christian and and bogan just
completely glossed over the fact that
bish p8 was by no means force they just
kind of discussed the bishop eight
position but let's not get into that but
but look at this nobody has any of the
tournament leaders yeah you guys are
useless terrible final thoughts
i can't believe you guys are failing me
so badly
[Laughter]
final thoughts
alejandro please romania i was gonna
remind you
thank you thank you guys yeah why what
what a date right i mean ali reza he
needs to snap back into it because
yesterday a very tough loss in a
complicated position but today he was
definitely winning in a lot of ways
multiple ways in which he could have
finalized the game and convert the
advantage and he did not do so and the
trend is just simply negative for him i
picked him as the tournament winner so i
need him to snap back but uh that game
between uh ritchie rapport and that that
was just insane i have to uh admit
richie really played a good game that
long castle that moved 16 that was just
wild stuff and he did get a winning
position but to collapse just like that
at move 40 well that's just
heartbreaking a lot of exciting games
for us for the commentators as well as
for the players and the fans and we have
plenty uh to come in the next few days
anastasia how about you yeah i felt this
uh really crazy tension and the plane
when you when i went few times there i
could see richard playing against bogdan
and bogdan running around his table with
few seconds on his clock you know so it
was really interesting and something new
for me i would say uh it was really
intense battle and um i mean but no
matter what happens on the boards we
still have the same result right plus
one one decisive game per day so i don't
know probably we have to change
something here i don't know where the
players well classical chess is
definitely fighting chess pure chess and
a lot of fun as well guys how about
yourselves
we're enjoying it we're i'm excited
it's been great it's a lot of fun
calling the action with your boat with
you both and alejandro your final
thoughts you guys have said it it's been
a fun couple of few days and i think the
tournament itself it's progressed really
interestingly it's not something i
expected fully but two candidates at the
bottom another candidate at the top very
big difference there it's an early
tournament still only round three but
we've seen a lot of action and a lot of
good good chess exciting chess and i'm
excited for the rest of the tournament
because it's been pretty good despite
the fact that it's only one decisive
result today thank you alejandro and of
course tomorrow will be round four
same time same channel we'll be looking
forward to seeing you all there in the
meanwhile uh hardy good night yep see
you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you